- Wake up, gamers! It's
time for Trash Taste!
It's time for Trash Taste!
- [Connor] Oh, that hurts me.
(cheerful music)
- Wake up, gamers! It's
time for Trash Taste.
I am your host for today, Garnt.
And with me are a bunch of sleepy boys.
- Why are you laughing?
- Oh, I just get reminded
of the honey wake up,
new Trash Taste episode.
- [Garnt] (laughs) I
love that. I love that.
- It was that energy.
- But yeah, I'm your host for today,
and with me is Connor and Joey.
- What up?
- And do you know what?
- You seem so just disinterested in...
- Yeah, I don't-
- Well, I mean, we've
been around for what?
90-something episodes now.
- We're the boys.
He's like, I don't fucking
know who's this guy.
- It's episode 90-something.
- This fucking Australian.
- You know who we are.
- Wake me up when they become the men.
Then I'll be woke. Then I'll be woke.
- I don't know if you
know my username but uh...
- I'm growing it back. I'm growing back.
- I'd argue I'm the only man in here.
- I think we all, since we all shaved
at all the same time I wonder
who's gonna grow back the fastest now?
- I think we're all kind of
growing at the same rate.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You got a black beard, through.
I think that doesn't count.
That's not full stuff.
- Wait, you got a black what?
- You got a black beard.
- I got a black beard.
Why does that matter?
- Because that means that-
- My favorite "One Piece" character.
- All right, badass pirate, by the way.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Really lacking in creativity
with this pirate's name,
but obviously you're...
- Wait till I tell you
about Whitebeard. (laughs)
- You'll never believe what he looks like!
- But yeah, finish your sentence, Connor.
- Black is darker than brown.
- [Garnt] Yes, yes, okay. Thank you.
- What a hot take.
- [Garnt] Thank you.
- Thus it stands out-
- Can we fact-check that?
Can someone fact-check that?
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- It stands out more.
- It stands out more?
- Yeah.
- Well, let's get the ruler out.
Let's get the ruler out
if you wanna go there.
- We're going down to the millimeter.
- Does your face feel
heavier with black hairs?
- (laughs) What? With black hairs?
- I know black paint is
heavier than white paint.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
- Is it actually?
- Yeah, it is true.
- That sounds like it could be true,
but that also sounds like it
could be completely bullshit.
- So are you saying that
a head of black hair
is heavier than any other color of hair?
- Well, on that scale where your hair
is not of a significant weight in general,
I think it's very minimal.
But like let's say, I learned this
'cause I was looking at weird
ways that planes save costs.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which actually ties in nicely
to our topic later, travel.
- [Garnt] Yes, travel.
- So if you're traveling,
the reason why you don't see black planes.
- Oh, 'cause they're heavier.
- It's heavier.
- Oh, I thought it just
would have cost a lot
to paint the damn thing.
- Well no, they paint it white.
- Oh, right.
- I would have thought
they painted it white
because of reflection.
- The heat.
- There's that, too.
- Or maybe like the heat that it takes in.
- There's that too, but
it's also twice as heavy.
- Twice as heavy?
- I believe black paint is
twice as heavy as white paint.
- Damn!
- Okay, I didn't know that.
Well...
- [Crew] White paint is
thicker than black paint
so I don't know if that fact is-
- That's just like black hair
nerfing itself, obviously.
That's like nature doing
a balance patch, right?
- I think it's something
to do with the pigments.
- We couldn't be too OP here.
- That's the weirdest balance
patch I've ever heard.
White hair is thicker than black hair
because black hair's
heavier than white hair.
- God's like, "Shave off a few pounds.
We gotta level the
playing field right now.
- [Crew] Got it wrong,
white paint contains
higher solid content than black paint
so white paint's actually heavier.
- Solid content.
- [Crew] No, no, actually it's-
- No, no, no.
- [Crew] No, no, referring to airplanes.
- They're referring to airplanes.
- [Crew] Yeah, no, that's what I'm saying.
- So wait, so white paint
is heavier than black paint
is what you're saying.
- [Crew] Yeah, 'cause
they require more pigment
in order to achieve the
same level of saturation.
- So then-
- Are you sure?
I'm pretty sure that's wrong.
- So then why do we not have black planes?
- [Crew] Yeah, this is
considered, this is-
- I think it's not that deep.
I think it's purely just because
it reflects more of the sun
and it doesn't turn the
plane into a fucking oven.
- I think you're-
- We're sounding like fucking
flat earthers right now.
Yeah, yeah, white paint's clearly heavier.
Okay, yeah, this is the
reasoning behind it.
- Is that what a flat earther uses?
Like, but have you seen
a black plane before?
How do you know?
(Garnt laughing)
We've clearly never been around the world.
- It's the same amount of pseudoscience
we're saying right now, I feel like.
None of us are even close to scientists,
and you could logically make
an argument for both, I feel,
and come out on top,
but if even the
fact-checkers can't confirm.
- [Joey] I mean, to be fair.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- It would make sense
if the planes were black
because then it'd be easier
to spot in the sky, right?
- No, it would be harder to
spot in the nighttime, right?
'Cause it would be
completely invisible then.
- But it's completely invisible anyway.
- This is so confusing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You can't see a bright-white
plane in the night.
- When I Googled,
"Does black paint weigh
more than white paint?"
Google said, "White paint weighs more."
But then I go to another
article that says,
"Black paint weighs more."
- So bottom line, we don't fucking know.
- So bottom line, nobody knows.
- No one knows.
- Google won't agree.
- Scientists cannot even
agree with each other
if black or white is
heavier than each other.
- Have you ever been in a plane
that wasn't painted white?
- I believe I have.
- The ugliest plane I've ever been on,
it was like a shade of like...
I was with you.
- easyJet, easyJet isn't that ugly.
- It was like a shade
of highlighter orange.
- easyJet isn't that-
- [Garnt] Oh, that is fucking disgusting.
- It's not that ugly.
- It's a gross color.
- I know they paint it
so that they don't have
to keep fixing the impurities
on the chrome or whatever.
- Oh, is that what it is?
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause it's cheaper to just
paint it again than it is to-
- Oh, I thought it was
like a branding thing.
- I mean, obviously it's like,
well, we have to paint it to save costs.
We might as well brand it a little bit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But is it heavier than
white or black paint.
- Probably. It's probably heavier.
But maybe the branding is
worth it for marketing.
- It's probably lighter, right?
Because it's easyJet so it's
got to be cheaper, right?
Surely, surely, surely.
- They gotta save the fuel somehow, right?
- Yeah, I don't know, that is...
Yeah, I guess now that I think about it,
I think that's the only plane I've been on
that's a completely
different color from white.
I've never really thought about-
- [Joey] I've been on the Pikachu plane.
- I was gonna say, aside
from the Pikachu plane.
- That's the ANA one, right?
- Yeah, the ANA yellow one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- All Nippon Airways.
- I thought I was gonna be more excited
getting on that plane, but
then I realized I can't see it
from the inside.
- You can't see it.
- [Garnt] You can't see
it. You can't see it.
- So it's like, oh, it
just looks like a plane.
- This is what it feels like
to get a sick skin in a first-person game.
It's like, dude, what a badass skin.
And then I can't see it.
- Yeah, then I can't see it.
- What an amazing skin.
- And what's the point? What's the point?
I never got that.
Why do people care about
skins in first-person games?
- So you can flex it on
all the people, right?
- Yeah, it's a flex on other people.
- You see your arms and
that's pretty much it, right?
- It's to show dominance
amongst your fellow players.
- Yeah.
- To make them know
if you have the samurai armor in "Halo"
you have an absolute massive cock.
(Joey laughing)
- I obviously have not played
enough first-person games,
but we're not talking about games today.
- What are we talking about?
- Because I thought it would be fun
to actually do a themed episode.
It's been a while since we've
done a themed episode, right?
- The music episode was the last one.
- This is the most scuffed
themed episode, by the way.
We haven't written anything down.
We're just winging it.
- Yeah, I mean, sometimes
we don't have to.
- Okay, by themed episode, we have a topic
that I hope we're gonna stick to.
Okay, I'm not gonna-
- [Connor] We're gonna
start talking about-
- I'm not gonna guarantee
that we're gonna stick to the-
- I guarantee we'll talk about
"Among Us" in 20 minutes.
- Yeah.
- Something's gonna happen.
- [Garnt] Probably, probably.
- Probably, yeah.
- But I feel like now that
we're getting ready to travel
and now that it seems like the country
is slowly opening back up.
I mean, at the time of recording,
Japan have finally let in
work visas and student visas
after like what, two years, is it?
- Like two and a half almost, yeah.
- And who knows what the
situation is going to be like
when this episode actually is released.
Maybe the country will be
open, and maybe a bunch of you
are going to be traveling
to Japan for tourism.
- Don't lie, Garnt. They're
not gonna open it, they're not.
- Well, the best case scenario is that
before the year ends people
start coming in again.
- So hopefully this
episode will come in handy
when you do eventually come to Japan.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But I mean, it's probably
gonna be a while, though.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I don't know.
- Lots of time to plan out your route.
- Well, you know, like
many have pointed out,
Japan, unfortunately, has an
extremely older population.
And old people don't really leave Japan,
and a lot of them have never left Japan.
Never even gone out of the country.
- Yeah.
- So a lot of the people,
I think it's like 80 or something,
90% of people agree with the travel ban.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Yeah.
- Whereas other countries
like Europe, UK, it's like,
"Well, I gotta have a
holiday in Benidorm."
"My cousin's from, he lives
in Poland," or something.
- Of course people in the UK
want the country to be open
because otherwise they'd
be stuck in the UK.
- [Connor] Yeah, exactly,
exactly, exactly.
- And where the fuck is there
to go on a holiday in the
UK, Butlins, you know?
- Yeah, which is why it sucks
'cause obviously a lot of
people from America, Europe
don't really understand
why Japan isn't opening up.
And it's like, well, you
need to kinda understand
the general consensus.
- Yeah.
Well, it's also because
Japan puts probably
the most amount of effort
into their domestic tourism.
- Well yeah, I mean, that ties
into the whole elderly population.
- Yeah, elderly people are like,
"I wanna travel, but I don't
want to get on a plane."
- Right, right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- "I know, I'll get on a bullet train
and go somewhere completely different,"
even though it's, you know-
- But let's just be optimistic.
For once guys, for once-
- Okay, fine. I'll stop
pessimistic for once in my life.
- [Garnt] For once, for once-
- That's a tall order, Garnt.
- For once, let's just be optimistic
and let's be like, you know what?
Maybe the old people
will change their minds
and be like, you know what, you know what?
Tourism, tourism good,
right? Tourism's good.
- Pretty sure every single war is started
because the old people
haven't changed their minds.
- Pretty much. (laughs)
So yeah, so let's say Japan is open
and you are planning a trip to Japan.
And you've heard us talk
about a fuckton of things
in like about close to
like 100 episodes now
so you don't know where to look
because we've been talking Japan for what?
About Japan for 100 episodes
so you don't really know
even where to start.
- Or maybe we've said a
location place and you're like,
"What or who is that?"
- Yeah, so we thought it'd
be fun to have an episode
where it's just collectively
what we actually recommend
or don't recommend about Japan.
If you're gonna plan a trip,
use this episode as like a
placeholder just to listen to it
and be like, "Oh, that
sounds interesting."
- And if the place
sucks, you can blame us.
- [Garnt] Yeah. (laughs) Pretty much.
- Obviously it depends on
how long you're going for.
That's the big one.
- Yes, yeah.
- We're talking about five days.
Maybe you can still go out of Tokyo.
- Five days, you can very
easily just stay in Tokyo
and have a great time.
- [Garnt] yeah.
- I mean, the first two
times I came to Japan,
I never left Tokyo.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Exactly, exactly.
- Mainly because I was scared and-
- Of the old people.
- Well, they were gonna beat me.
No, using the Shinkansens and
stuff is kind of intimidating.
- It is daunting, yeah.
- If no one's ever helped you do it.
- Yeah.
- It's intimidating
because obviously in
Tokyo there's a safety net
because a lot of things in Tokyo are built
with the idea that there's
gonna be people from abroad
coming to visit, right,
so a lot of places-
- [Connor] That too.
- A lot of places have,
you know, English menus still.
It's way more friendly and open
whereas if you go outside
of Tokyo you wanna go eat
and you're just like,
okay, this restaurant
probably doesn't have English on it.
- "Dark Souls" level difficulty incoming.
- This 70-year-old shop owner's
probably never seen a
foreigner in her life.
- Exactly, exactly, and it is daunting.
Even nowadays for us, even
though we're well-traveled,
sometimes, you know, I can do it
but sometimes I have to psyche myself up.
- I'm Japanese and I get intimidated.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause they look at me and they're like,
"You're not Japanese."
And I was just like,
"Oh God, what do I do?"
- I don't know when it happened.
I just stopped giving a fuck
about being awful at
Japanese a few months ago
so now I just talk.
- Yeah, you get over it.
- I don't know if I do good,
but I always get what I need.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So whether or not I'm
doing it right or not,
I get my tonkatsu.
- Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, just pretend. Okay, POV, POV.
You've just landed and you're
on a trip with the boys.
We're gonna show you around.
It's your first time to Japan.
- Life hack number one, fly to Haneda.
- Yes.
- Don't fucking fly to Narita.
- Yes, actually, actually
that is step number one.
- Top three locations in Japan
that suck ass, Narita Airport.
- Which, I mean, it might not be like,
you might not be able to avoid it
depending on which airline you fly with
'cause I know a lot of the major airlines
like Emirates and those all go to Narita.
- Yeah, yeah.
- NRT.
You want to go to HND if you can.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because you have to get a train.
- For one, Narita's not in Tokyo.
- Yeah, Narita's in Chiba, right?
- Yeah.
- It's like in the middle
of fucking nowhere.
- It's further from Chiba, isn't it?
- Yeah, also, to get into Tokyo
will cost you like 50 bucks.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, oh, it depends.
If you go on the Narita Express,
which is the most famous
bullet train-esque thing
from Narita airport it's
like, it's so expensive.
- It's actually like 80 bucks
if you go with the Narita Express.
- But there's a Skyliner
as well which you can get.
- But I didn't know about that
the first time I came to Narita.
- Because they don't advertise it.
- [Garnt] They don't advertise it.
- The only advertise the Narita Express
because it's convenient.
- Which is half, yeah.
- Yes, because the Narita
Express is the big kind of-
- It goes to Shinjuku, right?
- Yeah, it goes to Shinjuku.
- Yeah, okay.
- Yep.
- But yeah, it's the big
one that's advertised
about how to get into Tokyo.
And a one-way ticket there
using the Narita Express
costs about, I think, 80 to 100 bucks.
- Yeah, fuck that. It's like
200 bucks if you go to Narita-
- And the first few times I went to Japan,
I did not know that
there were other choices
that you could make.
So if you have to fly to Narita,
we highly recommend the Skyline.
- [Connor] Yeah, Skyliner.
- Which is cheaper than
the Narita Express.
- It's cheaper and it
stops at more places.
- Basically, when you get
off your plane at Narita
and you're done, go to the trains
and there'll be a bunch of ticket things,
but there'll be one specific
office that says Skyliner.
You can't miss it.
They speak English as well
so go there and ask them.
It's about 40 bucks, isn't it?
- And you pay like half the price, yeah.
- Yeah, and it's great.
- And it's just as fast.
- It's got a vending machine on the train.
- It's actually just as
fast which is why I'm like,
why is the Narita Express
twice as expensive?
- I don't know.
- Because they can get that money, though.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, go to Haneda.
Haneda's super easy.
You're basically in, where
are you near in Haneda?
- Nearly Odaiba.
- Yeah, yeah, Odaiba, Tokyo
Tower, all that kind of stuff.
- So you're actually,
one, you're in Tokyo.
Two, you can take the subway.
- Dude, the fucking monorail.
- You can take the monorail.
- Dude, the monorail
has a sick view, dude.
- You can take the monorail.
- The monorail's awesome.
Or you can just get a cab if you're lazy.
- You can get a cab, train, or monorail,
but the most aesthetic one
is definitely the monorail.
- A lot of the cabs have
the English-speaking
computer thing in it.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, I've never used it.
I shout at them like, "Go here!"
But yeah, I've never seen them,
maybe I should test it,
just see how it goes.
- Yeah, give it a go.
- So like we said, first step,
if you can, fly to Haneda.
We highly recommend you fly to Haneda
'cause you're gonna have such,
you're gonna have a way better experience.
It's gonna be less stressful
getting out of Narita.
- It's genuinely as well
just a really nice airport.
- Yeah, it's a really nice airport.
You get better views and it's also cheaper
so that's basically every reason
you could possibly thing of
to fly to a certain airport over another
if you have a choice,
if you have a choice.
- It's not normally expensive to go there,
but the cost of the train
tickets and transportation might-
- Make up for it.
- Might make up for it
or even save some money.
- Yeah, exactly.
So it offsets the costs a bit.
- It's like Gatwick
and Heathrow in London.
Gatwick's a joke. Gatwick's
basically in Brighton.
What's the fucking point of that airport?
- [Garnt] It's great for me.
- It's annoying as fuck.
It's literally not in London.
- What's the other airport
that you guys have?
- Heathrow, Heathrow.
- No, there's one more, right?
- Oh, oh, Luton? No,
don't fuck with Luton.
- No, no, no.
- Don't go to Luton.
- Then we got like Stansted and all shit.
I don't even count those
as fucking airports, okay?
- Those, getting to
Stansted and stuff like that
is more difficult than
the journey to France.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Right, right.
- It's awful, awful place.
- [Garnt] It's ridiculous.
- But we're talking about Japan right now.
- [Garnt] We're talking about Japan.
- So POV, you've just
landed in your airport.
Where are you gonna stay? Where
would you recommend staying?
What's the place-
- In Tokyo?
- APA Hotel.
- Oh god.
- Said no one ever!
- I mean, you got a lot of options, right?
Like, APA Hotel is
literally the same price.
- Don't. Don't do APA Hotel.
- Okay, but okay, but all right.
Yes, you might have to
deal with racist books
in your hotel room, which sucks,
but it's like the same
price as a capsule hotel.
- It's a closet.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because it is a capsule hotel.
- Yeah, I mean, you get
a bed, though. A window.
- I would highly recommend
Airbnbs. Airbnbs-
- I don't know, I don't-
- ... is my best experience
in terms of accommodation
staying in Tokyo.
- In Tokyo?
- Which might be difficult,
though, because of the recent Airbnb law.
- You get some weird, dude.
- That got rid of like,
80% of the Airbnbs.
- Even after 'cause I
have stayed in Airbnbs
since they got rid of a lot of Airbnbs,
and they are still like 10 times better
than most hotels in Tokyo.
- What?
- And the reason is because
most hotels in Tokyo,
they are just business hotels, right?
They come with the assumption
that you're just gonna stay,
like the guys staying there
aren't even gonna be in
the hotel at all, right?
- Yeah, unless you're
staying at like a Hilton,
everything else is just
like, yeah, a closet.
- Everything else is just
a closet or a shoebox.
- I don't know, I think
there's some decent ones
I think I've stayed in.
I don't know where though.
Pretty reasonably priced.
- [Garnt] For a decent price?
- Yeah, reasonably priced.
- I'm sure there is but I think-
- I think you have to look. You do.
- You do have to look,
but I feel like with
Airbnbs, there's just, you-
- Tokyo is absolutely
saturated with hotels.
There is a lot of hotels so you-
- It's 'cause they nerfed all the Airbnbs.
- Yeah, you can definitely
find a good hotel
if that's what you want 'cause I get it.
Sometimes you don't want
to deal with an Airbnb
'cause sometimes it's kind
of a weird experience.
- [Garnt] Really? I don't think so.
- Sometimes you get the
key in a really weird way,
and sometimes you're in
an apartment building
and you get stared at and stuff
and then also you're like-
- You go to the neighbor's
house, knock three times.
- Yeah, and sometimes you
don't really understand
how the locks work and stuff.
You're like, I get it.
A hotel sometimes is just
like, boom, card, in.
There's services, they can
do your laundry and stuff.
I get it, I get it.
- I just feel like-
- It's up to you. It feels like how-
- [Garnt] It's up to
you, but like to me like-
- Are you a Garnt or a Connor?
Or Joey just lives here.
- Connor just likes to
be pampered all the time.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- He just wants everything
done for him, you know?
- When I'm on a vacay, you know?
A little vacation. A little getaway.
I wanna worry less about things.
I want a safe in my room.
- Yeah, but you're also
probably staying at a Hilton.
- I'm not staying at a Hilton.
That's like a one-night
thing if I'm lucky.
I'm like, that's, the
wallet, oof, you know?
I feel like it's a waste
staying in a luxury hotel
for more than one day
'cause you wanna do shit,
you know what I mean?
You want to go outside.
Just get a hotel with enough room
where you can be comfortable
eating a cup noodle in it if you want.
- Okay, let me sell you
on the Airbnbs then, okay?
- All right, Garnt's
gonna pitch it to you.
I'll pitch a hotel to you.
- Okay, because with Airbnbs
you have more amenities.
You have a working fucking
microwave or one of those,
like, a lot of Airbnbs have
one of those mini grills
so if you wanna go to
FamilyMart or 7-Eleven
or Lawson's and buy the
famous fried chicken
that Connor and Chris have eaten a lot
but you don't want it cold,
you can perfectly just
grill it in your Airbnb.
- What do you mean? It's warm, what?
- It's warm when you buy it.
- What do you mean? It's
warm when you buy it.
- How long are you carrying around
this FamilyMart chicken for?
- I don't know, I don't know.
Okay, so like-
- Okay, I will say
that probably the one country on Earth
you don't need a microwave is Japan.
There's literally one on every corner
that you're allowed to use freely.
- That is true. Actually, that is true.
- (laughs) I feel like
you just realized that.
- I love as well how that was
your first argument is like,
"guys, they have microwaves."
- They have a microwave.
- Don't worry.
- Okay, but no, normally I
find that you get more room
in your Airbnb as well.
- [Connor] You can.
- A lot of the times
the hotel rooms it's just a shoebox
where you don't have room to walk at all.
- That's true.
- With Airbnbs-
- I've had both at Airbnbs.
- Yeah, with Airbnbs,
you actually have walking space sometimes.
You have a living space and a
bedroom space which is good.
Another thing is that a lot of Airbnbs
I've found in Japan especially,
the come with portable wifi, right?
So a lot of the times you
don't want to faff around
with getting data in Japan
because it's such a hassle,
but with so many Airbnbs,
basically about 90% of Airbnbs
I've stayed at, the owners are kind enough
to provide you with a portable wifi
which not only works as
the wifi in the Airbnb
but works as a portable wifi
which you can take with you
as you're traveling around Japan.
- Although I will say that I think most
if not all train stations
in the Tokyo area
have free wifi as well.
- It's pretty fucking
annoying to connect to though.
- Yeah, also every
McDonald's has a free wifi.
- True, I mean honestly,
just get it from the airport.
There's a bazillion of
these portable wifi-
- It is expensive as fuck though.
Data here is expensive as fuck.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it is.
- Especially if you're a tourist.
- You're gonna need it
though, honestly, I think-
- Yeah, you are going-
- Google Maps is just
literally your best friend.
- Yeah.
- I still use it.
- With the amount of walking
you're gonna do, especially.
- Everything, everything.
- If you have an international
plan for data or something,
I highly recommend that
because buying data here,
which is why I recommend Airbnbs
if they give you portable wifi.
Buying data here as a tourist
is really, really fucking expensive.
It's like $70 for like two
weeks or something like that
for four gigabytes.
- There's vending machines
at the airport that do SIM cards.
- Really?
- That do data-only SIM cards.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Damn.
- They are quite pricey, but you know,
it will do what you need to do.
'Cause I mean, Google
Translate is very good.
- And you can get a
vending machine experience
right off the bat.
- Right, yeah.
You're like, "Oh my God,
I've never bought a SIM in
a vending machine before."
- It's like, "Oh my God,
a vending machine that actually works."
- Yeah, yeah, there's also,
you can type in portable wifi
whatever airport you're going to.
There'll be ones you can get as well.
- Well, one piece of advice for me
that I want to tell people is get a Suica.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- Because that's gonna be
your best friend as well.
- This is a Suica card, okay.
This is the equivalent to an Oyster card,
although I don't believe
we use Oyster card.
- [Connor] Metro cards in the US.
- Like metro cards.
It's really easy because you can get one
at basically any machine on the metro
or anything like that here.
- [Joey] It's like 500 yen.
- Yeah.
It's like 500 yen, and you
can load it up immediately.
Every machine has an English option
and multiple other languages as well
so you don't need to worry
about learning Japanese
to buy a Suica card.
- It's super easy, and the
same with bullet trains.
Yeah, and also you can pay with it
if you don't wanna deal with cash.
Load it up, load up a shit-ton of money.
Every single fast food chain
and every single konbini will
accept it, every taxi driver.
- Most vending machines
as well, they accept it.
- Yeah, vending machines, trains, taxis.
- Yeah, with a Suica, yeah.
- Everything, yeah.
- Which is very, very useful
because if you don't remember this,
then you're gonna be
needing to bring cash.
Do not expect to be able
to pay by card anywhere.
Some places do accept it, but don't expect
to come into a place, even if it looks
like a big establishment that
should have a card machine,
a lot of places don't accept
cards or even credit cards.
- To be fair, it is
getting better recently.
- [Garnt] It is, it is.
- Yeah.
- A lot more places, and
especially since when I first moved
I remember like half the places I went to
didn't accept card at
all, but I feel nowadays,
most places in Central Tokyo accept card.
But also, you know, the
Suica's good because, again,
you can use it not just at a restaurant
but literally anywhere, so super handy.
- Yeah, but also, just
carry cash with you always
because you're going to need
it for something in Japan.
Even if you don't know
what it is immediately,
there's always gonna be one little thing
where this place doesn't
accept anything but cash
or a machine doesn't
accept anything but cash.
You're going to need it, so
don't assume we're like in,
Japan's like every other
first-world country
where we have a cashless society.
- Especially if you're going
to a mop and pop shop, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Where's it's like the old
restaurants and stuff like that,
they'll usually just be
like, "Nope, cash only."
- Yeah, yeah, and I know since
you're watching Trash Taste,
I'm guessing a lot of
you are weebs, right?
I'm guessing, I'm guessing. Maybe, maybe.
I don't know, I don't know, huh?
- Where are you going with this?
- Do you, would you, okay.
- What you talking about, Akihabara?
- We've talked about how
Akihabara is overrated, right?
- Yeah.
- Or how we think it is.
But I feel like it still is
one of the best places to go
if you just have like
a day or two in Tokyo
and you've never been
to Japan before, right?
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah...
- Because I feel like there's nothing
that really beats that
first-day Akihabara experience
because yes, yes, you can get figures
for a better price online or other places.
- Well, it's the magic. It's
the magic of the first time.
- Yeah, it's the magic, right?
It's like Disneyland but for weebs.
- Yeah, it's the fact that
literally every billboard
and building you see around
you is covered in anime.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which is like,
not really a place you can
experience anywhere else
in the world or rather,
anywhere else in Japan,
for that matter.
- [Garnt] yeah, exactly.
- It's kind of out of the way.
It's a little annoying
to get there, I'd say.
- I mean, it's like what?
Like 15 minutes from Tokyo
Station. It's not too bad.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah.
I say if you're gonna stay anywhere,
stay around Shinjuku, Shibuya
if you want a fun time.
- Yeah, I say Shinjuku probably
has the most stuff nearby.
- Yeah, if you want the
immediate connection.
- You have Ikebukuro, you have Shibuya.
- [Garnt] Yeah yeah, exactly.
- All that kind of stuff.
And then you the Akihabara
side of Tokyo which has-
- Which you can get to quite easily.
- Yeah, which you can just
cut straight across to.
Has like, Asakusa, Ueno,
all that kind of stuff.
- And you can easily
spend a day in Akihabara.
- [Joey] Oh, easily.
- [Connor] Totally.
- Easily and-
- Every time I go to Akihabara
even today I still find new shit to do.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- Whether you like retro games,
anime figures, classic stuff
like really old Transformer stuff.
Any kind of otaku stuff
is there. Maid cafes.
Boys, boys, boy-
- Don't go to a maid cafe.
Don't go to a maid cafe.
- Why not?
We should be helping them.
Yes, go to a maid cafe.
- Have you been to a maid cafe?
- Absolutely not.
- No, you don't wanna.
- But I can tell people to go.
- [Garnt] We've gone to like-
- Maybe I can get an affiliate account.
- Okay, here's the thing.
There are way cooler themed bars in Japan
and in Akihabara than maid cafe.
You've been to a bunch, Connor.
- I've been to so many.
- Yeah, you've been to so many
and you guys have made videos about it.
Sydney's making videos about it as well.
Everyone wants to go to a maid cafe,
but I feel like the maid cafe
is the most basic themed cafe
you could possibly go to when there are-
- It's an experience that I haven't had,
but I'm okay not having it,
but someone else can have it.
- I've had the experience,
and I have had a much funner time
going to the other themed
bars 'cause with maid cafes-
- Is it a bar? I feel like
it's an afternoon thing.
- It is an afternoon thing,
but it doesn't matter.
It's just cringe.
- Yeah, but like, it's fun.
- I hated it.
- I just want to see people go.
- Why do you want to see people go?
- 'Cause you wanna see people suffer.
- I want them to stay in business, right?
- I don't know.
- They're dying, right?
They're dying at the moment.
I want them to stay in business,
but I don't want to be the
one giving them the business.
- [Garnt] What was... (laughs)
- It's a cultural icon over-
- It is a cultural icon,
but I feel just-
- Give them your doki dokis.
- [Garnt] It's fun for a
change, it's fun for a change.
- Yeah, I feel with the amount
of other themed places in Japan,
and Japan is very good
at doing themed bars
and restaurants and stuff like that,
but I just feel like maid cafes
are kind of just becoming old
at this point where it's like-
- [Garnt] Yeah, because like one-
- You know what to expect at a maid cafe.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- But you don't know what to
expect at like, I don't know,
a Lockout or any of those
really cool kinda hidden,
underground bars and cafes, right?
- What's Lockout?
- Lockout is this prison-themed restaurant
that I've been to a few times.
- Where is it?
- There's a couple.
There is one in Shinjuku, I believe.
- Oh I think I, wait...
- Where you basically go underground
through a haunted house and you end up
and you eat inside of a cage.
- Is this where they scream half the time?
- Yeah, and then there's a
monster show and stuff like that.
- I think I went there
and I thought the food
was like the worst food
I ever had in my life.
- No, the maid cafe food
was a million times worse.
- No, I feel like the maid
cafe food, I don't know why,
it's just 100% of the
time it's horrible food.
I mean, it's on par with like, you know-
- It's an omurice.
- We only think it's good food
because a cute girl made it.
- No, no, I don't even think it's a cute-
- No, but most people feel that way.
So you're like, "Well,
the cute girl made it
so it must be good."
- See, and everything's
overpriced as well.
- Yeah.
- You know, everything's overpriced and-
- It's like 20 bucks
for the most mid omurice
I've ever had in my life.
- Yeah, yeah, right, right?
- You know where you get
a good omurice, though?
If you want like a brand one, Royal Host.
They do a good omurice.
- Dude, Royal Host is lit.
- [Garnt] Royal Host is fucking great.
- There's one in Akihabara.
This is like the Denny's deluxe.
It's so fancy and the
prices are ridiculous.
- This is what I feel
Denny's wished it was.
- Going to Japan and
just going to a maid cafe
with all the themed bars
or cafes that are available
is like going to America
for a burger joint
and going to McDonald's or
some shit like that, you know?
- Valid, valid, valid.
- That's like you have so-
- [Connor] White Castle, I'm there.
- You have so much choice
of so many different themes
and different unique concepts,
and then you go to a maid cafe
where they do the moe
moe beam on your food
and call it a fucking day.
That's it, that's it.
- Thank you for $50.
- Yeah, yeah, and
there's a lot more places
that you go to to a maid cafe.
Also, I wanna fucking die
when I go to a maid cafe.
- Just go to a maid
cafe at your local con.
It's probably the same
experience, to be honest.
- [Garnt] It actually is. It actually is.
- It's honestly the same experience.
- [Garnt] It's honestly
the same experience.
- Except the only difference
is the one in Japan,
you probably won't understand
what they're saying half the time.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
- That's the only difference.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- All right.
- You'll understand when
you go to a maid cafe.
- I don't wanna go. I don't wanna go.
I'm far too British to sit there.
- I want to see you at a maid cafe.
- You and Chris in a maid cafe.
- You and Chris at a maid
cafe would be the best.
- I can't. That's too much cringe for me.
- Yeah, I mean, even I'm more attuned
to the anime culture and
stuff and I'm just like,
I can't handle maid cafes at all.
- [Connor] No, I couldn't handle it.
- I think I'd rather
be seen at a strip club
or something like that.
- I would, I would rather.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- As opposed to that.
I feel like that's less
normal. Or more normal, sorry.
- Yeah, more normal.
But yeah, I mean, obviously get Akihabara
out of your system because you're gonna
want to go to Akihabara.
You're going to have a good time,
and if you're looking for places to go
then just look at our figures special.
We basically curated our figure special
to the places that we
like to shop in Akihabara.
Are there any other shops
you would recommend in
Akihabara that they'd go to?
- Oh God, there's so many. Why me?
- I like-
- Super Potato is really good.
That's the retro game place.
- That's like, what's the doujin store?
- Oh, Toranomon?
- Yeah, yeah, that one.
- Well, there's Toranomon
and there's Melonbooks,
which are two different ones.
Both are good.
- [Garnt] Yeah, that's like-
- Melonbooks I think
has four entire floors
of just doujin stuff so if
you like that then go for it,
but Toranomon has a better
selection, in my opinion.
- Yeah, I think so.
And that one has like
seven floors or something.
- That is like seven
or eight floors, yeah.
- Has like seven or eight floors.
- And there's two buildings as well.
There's two different Toranomons.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, because a lot of Akihabara
is, you go into a store
and it looks it's just a one-story store
'cause it's like fucking tiny, right?
It's full of stuff and then
you go in and then you realize
they have stairs, and
then you up the stairs
and you realize there's
another set of stairs,
and you realize that
it just keeps going up
and up and up and up, so a lot of-
- And suddenly you're in a mob.
- [Garnt] Basically.
- And also, the best thing,
I think, about Akihabara,
especially when you go
into the really small unmarked buildings
is that each of the floors
is usually a different store entirely.
So you could be in a
figure store at one point.
You go up the stairs and then suddenly
you're in an idol shop,
and then next moment you're
in a retro game shop.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Next moment you're in a tech shop.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
- And it's all
in one building, and it's great.
- Yeah, yeah, that's why you
can literally spend like hours
just in one random
building you stumbled into.
And of course the arcades there as well
because if you wanna
go to Japan, I highly,
like, you have to go to the arcades.
- Of course.
- Oh, go to the SEGA ones
'cause they have the fucking
mech pilot game, dude.
That shit was hot.
- Yeah, yeah.
What's that one called? And
I can't remember, but...
- Maybe don't go to the
ones in Akihabara though
'cause most of them are gone now.
- Yeah, that's true. That's true.
- All the SEGA buildings are gone.
- There's a ton of SEGA
buildings outside of Akihabara.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That have good games.
But the ones in Akihabara
have a lot of vintage games.
- Yes.
- They have
"Typing of the Dead"
still. They still got that.
- Yeah, they have an entire building
that just has an entire floor
full of old-school '80s arcades.
- It's got "Crazy Taxi"
It's got a few other games.
It's got "Time Crisis II" or three.
I can't remember which one it was.
- You can play a game on the arcades
for like 50 yen, I think.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- It's really good.
- Most arcade games
are just 100 yen which is $1.
- Takadanobaba, there's
the old retro game...
- Oh yeah, the one we went to, yeah.
- [Garnt] Oh, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That one was dope as fuck.
- Which is also right in
Shinjuku so easy to get to.
I can't remember what it's called.
Just type in arcade place Takadanobaba.
- Yeah, and yeah, I still
think my favorite arcade game
is the mecha pilot game.
- [Connor] Insane, dude.
- Have we talked about
it on Trash Taste before?
- We've mentioned it before,
but again, we don't know the name.
It's literally a hydraulic
mech in this arcade.
- You'll see it because you
literally are piloting a mech.
- You'll see people fucking tilting
and fucking, it's just sick.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it kinda reminds me
of these old-school rides
you'd see in malls sometime
or something where it's like
you're put into a capsule
and it's a roller coaster,
and the capsule tilts along
with the roller coaster that-
- [Joey] It's like 4-D.
- Yeah, like 4-D that you're seeing.
So imagine that except you
control the roller coaster, okay?
So when you pilot this
mech, it'll tilt and curve.
When you accelerate,
you feel the acceleration
and everything, it's so cool.
If you're a mecha fan,
or even if you're not,
it literally is the
closest you will ever come
to piloting a giant robot.
- And it's PvP.
- [Garnt] And it's PvP as well.
- You literally play against other people.
- And it's also like 100 yen.
- Yeah, and it's like five minutes a game.
- Yeah.
- It's really good.
- It's battle royal, but if
you are gonna go to the arcade,
you probably should look at a tutorial
about how to get the cards
and everything like that.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, save your progress.
- Because some of them, some of the games,
they will not let you go
past the tutorial stage
if you don't have a card.
- [Joey] True, true.
- Like basically, you pay the money.
- [Joey] Every rhythm game.
- Yeah, basically every rhythm game.
If you don't have a card,
you're basically just stuck
at the tutorial level.
- Yeah.
There should be a card
printer in the building
if it's a big arcade.
- Yeah. Most of the bigger ones have it.
- So if you don't have a
card, just go to a big one
and there should be a
machine that prints cards,
and there's like three
different ones, though,
so you need to figure
out which one's which.
It's really confusing.
I'm sure there's a guide online.
- I'm sure. Yeah.
- Also,
if you're having trouble,
"What the fuck is being said on screen?"
I just hold up Google
Translate to the screen
and genuinely it works.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Actually that
is a good life hack.
- Google Translate, it's not perfect,
but it'll give you the gist of everything.
- Yeah, it will be your best friend.
- You should use it.
- Yeah, Google Translate.
I didn't know this until I moved to Japan
where Google Translate
has a camera option,
where it will live translate things
that you put through the
camera of Google Translate.
It's been a life saver
for me in a lot of places
here in Japan.
- Is this hand sanitizer or water?
Let me find out.
- Yeah. Exactly.
And if you are ever in a restaurant
where it's all in Japanese,
then Google Translate camera
will be your best friend.
- Unless it's handwritten,
then you're fucked.
- [Garnt] Unless it's handwritten,
and then you just got to-
- Just read blindly.
- Then you just gotta hope
that you're with Joey, and
he'll translate it for you.
- I just say "Osusume."
I ask for their recommendations,
and I'm rolling the dice.
I'm like, "Please, for the love of god
give me something good," when I can't-
- Usually it's good. Usually.
- Normally. Normally it's good.
- Normally it's good.
- One time they gave me chicken carpaccio.
That was interesting.
- Oh wow.
- Raw chicken.
- Raw chicken?
- That was hard to stomach.
- Chicken sashimi?
- Yeah, that was...
I was like, "Damn, what
a great recommendation.
- Can't wait to get salmonella.
- Yeah.
- Mm.
- This episode is sponsored
by Athletic Greens.
You know, it's the year of 2022,
and I've put on a lot of weight,
as many of you have pointed
out in the comment section,
so this year I really wanted
to look after my weight
and general health, and one product
that has definitely helped
me with that personally
is Athletic Greens.
AG1 by Athletic Greens is an
essentialist nutrition company
that has created a movement around
simplifying your health routine.
It's not just for athletes.
It's for busy moms, dads,
rookies, first timers,
and everyone in between.
Yes, even anime YouTubers,
would you believe?
Athletic Greens contains
75 vitamins, minerals,
whole foods, super foods,
probiotics and adaptogens
in one convenient daily serving.
The special blend of ingredients
helps your body's nutritional needs
and supports gut health immunity,
energy, recovery, focus, and aging,
and taking Athletic Greens
every day is super simple.
You just take one scoop of the
powder, eight ounces of water
once per day, and that's it.
So if you would like to get
your body back into shape,
like I am trying to do this year,
then make sure to go
check out Athletic Greens
down in the description below.
Well, thank you to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
- But I mean, if you're into weeb stuff,
it's not all Akihabara.
Of course, that's like
the big mainstream place.
- I personally recommend,
for weeb stuff that's
not Akihabara, Nakano.
- Nakano Broadway.
- I was gonna say,
because I feel like with Akihabara,
you get overwhelmed.
Maybe that's what you want.
Maybe you wanna be
overwhelmed with weeb stuff,
but the problem with Akihabara
is that it's very, very much aligned with,
let's say, weeb culture,
as opposed to more other
underground anime culture,
which you can find more cool
stuff in Akihabara, I'd say...
No, no, no. More stuff in Nakano Broadway.
Because the way I describe
Akihabara is it's just like,
imagine if you're on the
convention floor, right?
That's basically Akihabara,
where you're in the dealers hole.
That's Akihabara.
Nakano Broadway is more
like the artist alley,
where you can get more of like
the more stuff that's not-
- There's a few shops around there that-
- Like the unconventional stuff.
- The unconventional stuff, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In Nakano Broadway, there's
a store on the first floor
where they just sell
nothing but old anime cells.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- That place is really dope,
and then there's other ones
that are from 40s and 50s Japan,
styled stuff and everything.
Huge manga store there.
- If you like retro games,
and you want Game Keeper
games or something,
that's really cheap,
there's a place called Book Off.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- Book Off sell a lot of retro games.
- Secondhand stuff.
- Yeah.
- I mean that's...
- There's so many, dude.
I saw like Super Mario Sunshine
inbox for like 600 yen.
So like five bucks.
- Nice.
- Yeah, Book Off, it's like
a big chain here, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- You can find Book Offs
in most major places, there
is a Book Off somewhere.
So if you want a good
deal for secondhand stuff-
- There's a bunch of them.
There's Book Off, which is mostly
focused on books and
games and stuff like that,
and then there's another one called...
the name's horrible, but
it's called Hard Off.
(Garnt laughing)
They didn't really think that one through.
Which is more kind of
like secondhand appliances
and you can get games at Hard Off as well.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, and then Book Off,
you can also buy
secondhand clothes as well.
- There's a lot, yeah.
- It's pretty good.
And then there's another
version of the off series.
- Keep Off.
- Write Off.
I don't know what-
- Yeah. Sigma Off.
- Fuck Off.
- Yeah.
My big problem with Akihabara
isn't just the fact that it's all anime,
which, that's not really an issue.
It's just you can't
really find anything else.
So if you want to go out
for a nice meal afterwards,
there's nothing really around Akihabara.
- I think the only thing
I've had in Akihabara
is the Royal Host, and the-
- Ramen.
- Yeah, the ramen.
- A lot of ramen places.
- Or if you want a drink-
- It's decent ramen,
to be fair.
- Or if you want, like... sorry, go ahead.
- No, no, no. I was about to say,
but what I love about Nakano,
is that Nakano not only has
this kind of cool underground,
like, especially in Broadway,
the whole anime and weeb shit,
but once you go outside of the
Broadway section of Nakano,
which is just one building,
then it has some of the
coolest bars and restaurants,
and stuff like that.
I mean the JoJo bar is in Nakano.
- Yeah, exactly.
So that's the perfect
reason to go to Nakano.
That's a business I do
wanna stay afloat, Connor.
- Yeah.
- It's like Grinder.
- Fuck yeah.
- Go to DIO in Nakano, the JoJo bar.
It's fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
That's a place that we
want to stay in business.
Not the maid cafes.
- Yeah.
- Bring your business to
the JoJo bar, DIO in Nakano.
- You have to check that
they're open on Twitter though.
- Yeah, you have to follow them on Twitter
to see if it's open.
- Yeah, even though the
Google hours say whatever,
he tweets out whether he is open or not.
- Yeah, because it's
literally just one person.
- It's one dude, yeah.
- Yeah.
So yeah.
- Very cool.
- That's another reason to go to Nakano,
but aside from that,
there's just so many other cool places
and other cool restaurants and bars
that you can go to in Nakano,
and it's one of those places where
you can just stumble upon a place.
You don't need to Google, you
don't need to do a million
and Google which one's like
five stars, or something.
It's one of those places that
you can just get lost in,
and you're just like,
"Oh, that place, that place looks cool."
- Because everything's so tight knit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And there are so many
tiny restaurants and bars
and stuff like that in Nakano.
- Yeah, because when I
go on holiday, right,
I'm not the kind of person
who is just planning out everything.
I don't have itinerary.
What I prefer is just
going into a cool area
and just discovering stuff for myself.
That's the kind of
traveler that I am, and-
- Wow.
- Yeah, and Nakano-
- What kind of traveler he is.
- Well, well, well, Garnt,
what a traveled man you are.
- No.
- The monk in him sure knows.
- Of course, of course, of course.
And Nakano is one of the
best areas for that as well.
- I agree. I agree.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I wonder.
So we've gone to Akihabara.
What else is something
that you might consider?
You know, I think, even though, you know,
we don't really go there
that often anymore,
because I feel like it's very much a,
you've gotta do it while you're here.
Just do a tabe/nomihodai.
Just go crazy for it.
To go to like a cheap izakaya.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- Eat and drink everything.
It's like X amount for one hour.
- Do you remember how many
times we went to Kinokura
and did the two hour?
- Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
- The two hour lookout.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You've gotta go to a Kinokura
if you like to drink and eat a lot.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Kinokura Monday,
it's a hundred yen beers.
- Oh, boys, boys.
- Yeah, yeah.
- If there's two words you
need to learn in Japan,
it's none of this like, fucking,
"Konichiwa, Arigato" shit.
- Korya, open discussion.
- Yeah, korya. No, no, you
don't need to know that.
Fuck that shit.
Osusume, as Connor just
said, and nomihodai,
which is all you can drink,
which is the only two words
you really need, right?
- Tabehoudai.
- Or tabehoudai.
- Tabe and nomihodai.
- Yeah. Tabe is food.
All you can eat, all you can drink.
- I feel like you'll know it's nomihodai,
because it'll be very bright
and it'll have a number.
- Yeah.
- It'll be like 2000 something.
- And you'll see a picture
of a lot of drinks.
- Yeah, it'll be like 2000 something or...
if you see a timer, like
2000 plus 60 something.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You're either about to hire a person
for illegal activities,
or you are going to be
having an all you can drink.
So fun for all the family, really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Basically, yeah, just go to an izakaya.
Do you recommend going to a chain one?
- Yeah. Fuck yeah.
Dude, go to a Kinokura, dude.
- Yeah, Kinokura or like-
- It's got English
on the tablet.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Kinokura, or a Torikizoku,
or any of those chains.
Although it's not the highest
of quality in terms of food,
but I think if you want-
- Tori, Tori, what's it called again?
- Torikizoku.
- Yeah, that's decent to.
- Torikizoku is good.
I really like Torikizoku.
- It's literally just all yakitori.
- Yakitori, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think they have nomi and tabihodai.
- Yeah, they do.
- So you can get all you can
eat and all you can drink
in meat and beer.
I mean, come the fuck on.
- And honestly,
we're saying the food isn't that good,
but I remember coming here.
- Oh no, it's bomb. It's bomb.
- It's fucking amazing compared to,
probably where you're from.
- We're probably being spoiled
living in Japan.
- We have been spoiled.
Our food tastes, we've become food snobs.
- I remember the first day
that Connor came to Japan
and I took him to a Kinokura
the moment he got off the plane,
and he was like, "It's a
hundred yen for a beer?"
And I'm like, "Yep."
And he was like, "Oh, but
it's probably a cup, right?"
- No.
- Out comes are fucking pint.
- Yeah, it's good.
- And he's like,
"This is the greatest
country in the world.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Yeah. Literally.
- No, the food is good. I forget.
I forget, because I've
been living here so long.
If you're traveling out of England,
the food is like fucking 10 out 10
compared to anything
you can get in England.
- This is just like a basic hour,
obviously if you'd been to Japan a bunch,
you would fucking know this shit.
You do whatever you want.
But this is for the
boys and girls out there
who are coming to Japan
for the first time,
having a good time.
- Yeah. First time.
- Expect everywhere you go to
have the most 10 outta 10 food
because you will have the
most 10 outta 10 food.
- And learn, go do karaoke.
Just, just go.
- Yes.
Speaking of nomihodai.
- Yes, speak of nomihodai,
you will definitely need to
know that word for karaoke,
because basically every
karaoke has nomihodai,
and I don't know why you'd
want to do karaoke sober.
Maybe you do. Maybe you
have a great singing voice.
I don't, I need to be drunk to sing, okay?
- It will probably be a bit awkward
because they don't have any English help.
Getting it, just, I mean,
yeah, you'll be fine.
- I'm sure they're used to foreigners.
- Yeah, just hold up the
number of hours you want
in your hands, and then say nomihodai,
and they'll tell you a price,
and then you just say yes.
- And I feel there's like a
weird, I guess like stereotype
of this karaoke culture outside of Japan,
because I think when most
people think of karaoke,
they think of like open mic,
on a stage and stuff like that,
which is like, I'm not for that.
I think that's kind of cringe.
- I love it, dude. I love it.
What are you about?
- No, no, I can't do it.
- I love that. "Tequila".
- I like singing in front of
my friends and people I know
in a room, 'cause that's fun.
We can all hang out and stuff.
- Okay, so the reason I'm not really a fan
of the open mic karaoke.
- [Connor] I love it.
- Is because you only get two
types of people that do it.
It's either one, the
fucking amazing singers
who are basically auditioning
for X-Factor or something the next day,
or you just get the piss heads
who just murder your ears.
- I am the latter.
- The thing is, there is no in between.
- Yeah.
- You either come out
getting a free concert,
or you come out regretting
the fact that you have ears.
There is no in between.
- There's never a moment
where someone finishes singing
and you're like, "Hey, that was okay."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I think I like karaoke.
There's karaoke bars in Japan
where you can sing with everyone else.
I love them. They're so fun.
- Because I remember-
- Everyone gets involved,
everyone in the bar gets hyped.
- Yeah, but you can do
that with a small crowd
in a karaoke room, right?
- Yeah, but what if you
just wanna like meet
some random Japanese people?
Those things are pretty fun.
- Oh yeah, I mean, but I feel
there's better ways to
meet Japanese people
than a fucking open mic karaoke.
- No, no, it's the best
way. It's the best.
- But like, I remember,
'cause I'd never really thought about it,
'cause in my head, karaoke was always
the Japanese style karaoke,
like in a room, right,
so I remember when Felix came to Japan
and I really wanted to
take him to a karaoke.
In his head, he was like, "No,
I don't wanna go to karaoke."
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "Why?"
And he's like, 'cause he
thought about the open mic shit,
- Yeah.
- And he's like,
"Nah, I don't wanna do that."
And I'm like, "Oh my poor
sweet, innocent child.
You don't know what real karaoke is like."
And I took him. Connor was there.
- Yeah.
- I went with Dave as
well, from Boyinaband.
- Yeah.
- And he was like,
that's the most fun that
he's ever had in Japan.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like,
"I fucking told you."
- Yeah, it's honestly like
one of the funnest things
you can do in Japan, I feel like,
because I think the thing
about Japanese karaoke
is that the song selection
is fucking godly.
You wanna sing anime songs?
Of course you wanna sing anime songs.
You have all the anime
songs at your disposal.
But if you can't sing the Nihongo,
then you got basically every major song
from England and America.
- Yeah, you just pick up the tablet
and there'll be foreign
songs or something.
English option.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can sing Korean songs
and Chinese songs as well.
- I think the Japanese karaoke
has a better selection of English songs
than English karaoke in England.
- I get that.
- It's insane, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, it's one of
the funnest experiences
you can do with your mates.
- Oh, you can also get costumes.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, we did that,
when we first came to Japan, didn't we?
- You can go down to the first floor.
You'll know it's a karaoke building,
because it will look like something
out of cyber punk, outside.
They always had the neon signs
or the really bright signs.
- Yeah.
- And it's massive,
like seven floors.
- If you see neon signs,
it's gonna be pachinko or karaoke.
- The inside looks like a palace.
Actually, that's pachinko.
They all look like a palace inside.
- Yeah, go into the building.
If your ears are bleeding,
it's probably a pachinko.
If it's not bleeding,
it's probably karaoke.
- Yeah, because karaoke's
actually soundproofing,
got the hatches.
- All the pachinko buildings
have tinted windows,
so you can't see in.
- Yeah.
- So they're like frosted.
- But you'll know it's a pachinko building
'cause when someone enters
it, and the door's open,
you can hear that shit from a mile away.
- Yeah, and like, I feel like...
do the karaokes, if they
want to sing anime songs,
or Japanese songs,
do they have like a function
in a lot of karaokes now
where you can actually, where
it actually spells it out,
not in like katakana, but in English?
- There's some. Some do it.
- Okay.
- It's super rare there,
and the selection is super limited.
- You're better off just
looking up the English lyrics
on your phone.
- Yeah, that's true. That's true.
That's true.
- But yeah,
but they have like TV sizes
where they actually play
like the visuals and stuff,
which is pretty dope.
- My favorite things
is seeing what kind of
music videos they play
with your songs that
you sing during karaoke.
Because it's like, I dunno-
- Karaoke videos are my favorite.
- Who films that? I'd like... okay.
- I think it's the same people
make the bowling animations.
- Yeah, probably.
- It must be.
- So if you've never
been to an Asian karaoke,
a lot of the music videos,
it's basically like the
equivalent of a stock image,
just with music videos, right?
So you'll have this
random, I don't know...
One of my favorite ones is where-
- It's the white guy at the bar?
- It's the white guy... yeah,
yeah, you know the one I mean.
- It's just like a sad dude at a bar.
- This is such a specific reference
that only one person will get.
- Because it appears
like every four songs.
- Yeah, or it's like, every Queen song,
it's just these five people
just dancing on a dance floor
in this empty bar,
and it looks like the saddest
fucking party of all time.
- It's like a school prom.
- Yeah, right?
- It's my favorite. I love it.
- Yeah, and I dunno what,
I dunno what company fucking
film this karaoke music video.
- It's all British, I think.
They're all from the UK.
- That's the thing,
because it's not Asian people.
It's all either British or
American people that I've seen.
It's so weird.
I actually, that's a
really interesting topic.
I would actually wanna know,
who actually filmed these?
Who made these?
Who actually made these?
- You could ask Joysound or something.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Where are these videos coming from?
- Yeah, can you link me to the video?
- Because they look like
they're filmed in the '90s.
- Yeah.
- They're really old.
- Yeah, because most of them are still
on a four by three aspect.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- They're the best.
- Yeah, you know you've picked a good song
or a popular song when they
have the actual music video.
You're like, "Oh, we're
singing good today, boys.
We're singing good."
- Well, most of the time
when you're selecting the song,
it says if it comes with
the actual music video.
- Yeah. True.
- And if it doesn't,
then you're gonna probably
get a white guy at a bar.
- Yeah, because the saddest thing
is when you select a
banger song or something
and you're like, "I'm ready,"
and then you hear a midi track,
and you're like, "Oh, no."
- It's always midi.
- Yeah, they're all midi.
- It has a fucking banger
like guitar riff or something,
and it's just like, "Choo choo choo."-
- It's like the worst
midi sounding guitar ever.
It's like, "Meep meep meep."
But it's fun.
- But no, karaoke is great,
especially with your mates,
and it's a great way to
just open up with your mates
because normally you go to a karaoke bar
and you don't really wanna sing,
'cause you don't wanna embarrass yourself
in front of strangers,
but with Japanese karaoke,
you can just embarrass yourself
in front of mates, equally,
and it's a hell of a fun time.
- But if you wanna embarrass yourself
in front of your mates in another way,
you can also go to an onsen, as well.
A public bath.
- Of course. Yes.
- Which I think is a much taller
hurdle for a lot of people.
- I recommend just going
to, you can book ryokans,
which normally have onsens.
You can book them on booking.com.
- Yeah, and even if you
have tattoos, you can-
- You can get private ones.
- If you have the expendable
income, then you can.
- Where would you
recommend for that, though?
Because before, we had the
massive onsen in Tokyo.
- It's gone.
- Onsen Monogatari.
- Yeah, yeah. Onsen Monogatari.
Unfortunately, we can't
recommend that anymore
because that was...
- It's gone. That's so sad.
- I'm so sad, because that
was the perfect onsen to recommend,
because you go to the onsen.
- Salu's not a real one.
- And then you'd go to DiverCity
and just see the massive
Gundam, and you're like,
"Goddamn, what a perfect day trip."
You know, that's the perfect day trip.
Unfortunately, that's
not available anymore.
- I still think some of the...
well, I mean, it depends
how far out of Tokyo
you want to go into.
I mean, there's a lot of
like small bath houses
in and around Tokyo, in
the more suburban areas,
but that's not really an onsen.
If you want like the onsen experience
without going too far out of Tokyo,
I'd say Hakone is probably-
- Yeah, Hakone is pretty good.
- That's in Kanagawa, which
is one prefecture across,
but you can-
- You can get a bullet train.
- Or not even you can get the romance car.
- Romance car.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Romance. Uh-huh.
- Yeah, I dunno why it's
called the romance car,
but it's halfway between a bullet train
and a regular train.
It's more boujee than a regular train,
but it's not as fast as a bullet train,
and you can go directly
from Shinjuku to Hakone
in an hour, I think.
- Yeah.
- It's relatively cheap as well.
- And yeah, Hakone is
a really, really nice
little cute small town.
- I love Hakone.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
There's this really small Eva
store right on the station.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which I go to every time. I dunno...
And the reason for that is because Hakone
is what they base Tokyo-3 off of.
So if you've seen "Evangelion"
and you've seen the movies,
you will recognize the trains
that like that they use there,
'cause they look exactly
like they do in Eva.
You'll be like,
"Oh, I see Shinji right there
listening to her headphone.
Oh, look."
- Weebs, discuss.
- And you walk around,
you see vending machines
and Asuki and Mari and
Shinji is everywhere.
- I really recommend, if
you want a nice kind of,
maybe a two day trip outside of Tokyo,
because Hakone is not only really good,
especially if you love Eva, of course,
but like also there's the Jigokudani,
which is the sulfur plumes of
like the mountains of Hakone
is really nice.
- I've never been there before.
- It's really dope.
You go up this huge, I
was about to say monorail,
it's not a monorail, it's like
a... what do they call it?
Like this... fuck... what do they call it?
It's like a, not a ski lift, but... what?
- Gondola?
- Yeah. Gondola, that's it?
Yeah, you go up this gondola
from the base of this lake in Hakone,
and you go up into the mountains
and you get this really,
really nice view of the lake
and on a good day, if the
weather's really good,
you can see this perfect
view of Mount Fuji as well.
So that's really dope.
And then you go into this little valley
and you go into this
place called Jigokudani,
which is called Hell's Valley.
Japan has a couple of Hell's Valleys.
- Oh I know. Yeah.
Isn't there one in Hokkaido, as well?
- There's one in Hokkaido as well.
And there's also one
around like Gifu as well.
But, yeah, it's just this
really cool sulfur plume place
where you can get really close
to volcanic sulfur plumes.
It kind of smells like
farts the entire time.
- Sulfur does like farts.
- But it's kind of a really
cool, unique experience.
Yeah, I personally recommend it.
It's a good day trip.
- Yeah, because I really,
Hakone was the first hot
springs town that I went to
and I really enjoyed myself.
The one thing I will say
is, if you go to Hakone,
it's really weird,
because I went to Hakone,
and I expected it to be
something, not similar to Tokyo,
but you expect to go to a hot spring
and then you expect to walk
around and explore somewhere,
but a lot of ryokans,
they expect you to stay
at that one establishment
for the entirety of your trip, right?
A lot of these hotels, and
a lot of these ryokans,
will have everything you
need within that facility
because they don't really expect
you to go out and explore,
because normally there
isn't really much to explore
in that immediate area, unless
you take a bus or something,
right.
- Yeah.
- At least that's my experience.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So don't expect...
Like, you can go explore, but
if you want to go explore,
you probably need to
plan it out a bit more
because the place you're staying in
isn't necessarily going to be near
a lot of tourist attractions.
- Yeah.
- Especially if you're
staying at a ryokan.
Having said that, if
you do stay in a ryokan,
be prepared to get up and
eat fucking breakfast, okay.
That's one thing which-
- At an egregiously early time.
- I'm not sure if I am a fan of it,
but if you do stay in a ryokan,
ryokans are great, right.
Ryokans are great, because I
feel like, in terms of hotels,
they're like the most
aesthetic place you can stay.
- Oh yeah.
- You are pampered there.
It's great.
- It's the most authentic
Japanese accommodation experience.
- Yeah, exactly, and they
normally have the nicest onsens
that you could find.
- Oh, you normally sleep on a
futon, though, on the floor.
So not a bed. So, if that's
something you might...
- But if you want that
authentic Japanese experience.
- Yeah, I like it. I like it.
- Futons, I feel like, are
better than beds sometimes.
- Yeah, but right,
people might not want to.
- True.
- Some people might
have a thousand thread count.
- They might be thinking,
"Where's my bed,"
when they get there.
- "There you are."
"Is that it?"
- Yeah.
But if you don't come down for
breakfast at the agreed time,
they will find your family
and they will kill everyone you love,
or at least that's what I get out of-
- It's included in the cost as well,
so that's why they're
normally quite expensive,
'cause dinner is normally included.
- Yeah, they don't want you wasting money.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, these dinners are
normally really large courses,
so they're the reason
why a ryokan seems...
Ryokans are normally like
what, 3, $400 a night minimum,
and that's 'cause half of
that has gone to the food,
if not more.
- The food. Mm-hmm.
- Yeah, you will be eating like a king.
You will be eating like king.
So if you see the price of the ryokan,
don't get too shocked at the price,
because you are paying
for the food as well,
and it's normally
really, really good food.
- High quality.
- It's high quality.
It might be even a bit too much sometimes.
- You'll get a good taste of
local dishes, though, normally.
- Yeah.
- They use local ingredients.
- Yep.
- And it's certainly
a really good way to
just try Japanese food
that you normally wouldn't order.
Like, I'm never gonna order
half the shit they give me.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- Because half of it
is super slimy.
- Yeah.
- But I'll always eat it,
because I don't want to
have to make eye contact
with that small Japanese lady
who asks me why I didn't like it,
which they have done many times.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
They do, so now I just eat everything.
- I just eat everything.
- I eat everything,
but originally when I
didn't eat something,
they would sometimes just
stare at me and be like,
"Why didn't you eat it?
What's wrong? Are you okay?"
- "What's your address?"
- "Are you sick? Do you have COVID?
Are you dying?"
- "I will find you."
- "I will kill you."
- Best advice. Best advice you get.
- Pillow over the face.
- That's something you
feel so intimidated.
But no, I'd even recommend going to ryokan
to try the traditional Japanese food
over even going to a restaurant, right.
Because with a restaurant,
you don't know what to order.
You look at the menu and it's like,
"I don't know what I'm going to like,"
but it's kind of like,
ryokan food is kind like
a tasting menu, you know?
You kind of get a little
bit of everything.
- Lots of little small chunks
of a lot of different things.
- A little bit of everything.
You're gonna find something you like,
some things you don't like,
but it's a great way to just easily
get the traditional Japanese experience.
Just don't miss breakfast, because...
Did I hear you say they
came to your room once
and woke you up to get
breakfast, or was that Chris?
- Yeah. A woman literally...
I was with Chris.
- Right.
- I think I was on a
journey across Japan trip
and one morning I got...
Well, the night prior, I got very drunk.
So that morning.
- As we do sometimes.
- As you do, and then the
morning of I was very hungover
and the lady kept knocking
on my door being like,
"Breakfast ready," and I'm
like, "Yeah, shut up, shut up.
I have a throbbing headache right now,"
and then she just fucking walks in
and just rips the sheet
off me, and I'm just like,
"What are you, my mother?"
- No way. Really?
- Yeah.
- What the fuck?
- And she was like,
making sure you're alive, and
I was like, "You fucking...
Alright."
- She came in and ripped it off?
- Yeah, or like slowly took it off.
- That's even worse. That's more creepy.
- And I'm like, for one,
I'm freezing my ass off,
two, I have a throbbing headache,
three, how did you get in?
- What the fuck? I've never heard of that.
- Yeah. That's an exception,
though, that's an exception.
- That's something else.
- Most places,
they'll just ring you up
on the phone to make sure
that you're not dead.
- I've also stayed at a-
- Five more minutes,
mum. Five more minutes.
Come on. Please.
- I've also stayed
at modern ryokans, if you
will, that are more like,
they have beds like.
- Like western ryokans?
- Yeah, and they're way more modernized,
and Hokkaido has a really nice one.
- I think that's called a hotel.
- Well, it's like, it has...
It's weird, 'cause it'll have tatami mats,
but it'll have a bed and it'll have-
- Oh, I know what. Yeah, yeah.
Those are usually more
higher up, though, right?
- Yeah, but they normally...
Because I find that the
prices aren't different.
The really traditional
ones sometimes cost more
than the more modernized ones
because they charge a shit ton for food,
or maybe they have a lot of workers.
That's one thing. They have
so many workers at ryokans.
An insane amount.
- They do.
- But also sometimes the service is nuts.
- Yeah.
- The moment you turn up,
there's like four of them greeting you.
They'll take all your
bags right away, and then,
oh my God, it's so intense.
I'm like, "Jesus Christ.
What is happening?"
- Sometimes it's a bit too intense, right?
Because sometimes you're just like,
"Okay, I- I- I know you're wanting
to make me feel comfortable,
but you're making me feel a
little bit too comfortable now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I stayed at three or four
recently with Chris, on a video,
and it was really, it was basically-
- I remember I walked up to one,
and as we were driving into the ryokan,
there was like 10 employees all lined up,
just like slowly bowed,
I was just like, "Bro, I'm
not the queen. Chill out."
- Yeah, literally, you feel like it, dude.
- You feel like royalty, in the best way.
- Yeah.
- It's good.
There's a lot of different price points
and different kind of
variations of onsens.
I think I've seen the one
with the snow monkeys.
- Oh yeah.
- And that was amazing,
because the whole town is an onsen town.
- Mm.
- Which town is this?
- I think there's two. I think
this one's called Yudanaka.
- Yudanaka. Yeah, yeah.
- Yudanaka, and the other one was,
which was famous for having
a big, big onsen pit.
You can't go in it, but, what's
it called... Ku something.
I don't know.
- Yeah, there's a couple of them.
- And yeah, honestly, it's at Nagano.
- Whereabouts is it?
- Nagano, so you can drive from
Tokyo if you really want to.
- You can easily get the bullet
train as well from Tokyo.
- Get the bullet train to Kusatsu.
- Kusatsu, yeah,
that's like the top three
onsen cities or towns.
- That was so good, because
we stayed in an onsen
that was literally like one
foot away from the town center.
- Mm.
- Really cool.
Really, really cool area.
- The other top three I went
to was Hira onsen, as well.
That's in Shizuoka.
- Oh, I remember.
I want to go to that one.
- That one's really good.
- That's the one where Chris and I
bathed in a thousand year old log.
- That place.
- Oh, that one.
- Yeah.
- A thousand year old log.
- Yeah, there's a bath made
out a thousand year old log,
and it was actually really, really nice.
That's in Hira.
- When you guys book onsens,
well I know that's not
a problem for you, Joey,
but do you go with the English sites
or do you go with the Japanese sites?
- You can use booking.com super easily.
- Okay.
- Unless it isn't on booking.com,
which is quite rare, actually.
- Yeah, I've never really seen anything
that's not on booking.com.
- It's all on booking.com.
- Okay.
- Which is really weird.
You'd think super
traditional, but now dude,
you can book it all on booking.com.
- Yeah.
- Have they modernized?
- Have they actually?
- They might have.
- I've never seen a ryokan
that I wanted to go to
that wasn't on booking.com.
- Mm.
- Right.
- I don't know why that is,
'cause some hotels aren't on booking.com.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Which is really weird.
But yeah, I stayed at a place one time
where they didn't have the onsen built in,
they had a hot tub,
so they would fill the
hot tub with onsen water
they brought in via truck.
- That's weird.
- So is that really an onsen?
- It's an onsen if it
has onsen water in it.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
If you fill a bathtub with an onsen water,
that's technically an onsen.
- It's an onsen.
- If I bring sea water in
my bathtub, is it the sea?
- It's the sea bath.
- Is it the sea?
- Well, yeah. It's a sea bath.
- A sea bath. Yeah.
- It's a sea bath, is it the sea though?
Is it a hot spring?
- Well, there's no place
where you can go for the TM onsen.
- You know the word onsen
just means warm spring?
- Yeah, yeah.
- True.
- You can just get it.
What makes it onsen is
that it has the fucking-
- Minerals.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And every single onsen
has the pH sign and stuff
that tells you what's outside of it.
So they're really strict on
what can and can't be an onsen.
It's really strange.
- Yeah, legally speaking.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
But yeah, I highly recommend
just getting over your
fear of getting naked
in front of your mates, or whatever,
and getting in an onsen.
- Is that a problem?
JoJo fans?
- I think, yeah,
for a lot of people.
- JoJo fans,
this does not apply to you.
- Yeah, doesn't apply to JoJo fans.
- Yeah, because I remember
there's been a couple of my friends
who just refused to go to an onsen
just because they were uncomfortable
with getting naked in
front of me or the mates,
and I'm just like-
- Dicks out for the boys.
- Yeah, I'm like, dicks
out for the boys, dude.
We all have 'em. It's like, who cares?
You'll get over it in five minutes.
- It's a bonding experience.
- It is.
- It is. It is.
- It's a bonding experience.
- I love saunas, dude.
- Yeah.
- I dunno if that's like
a white person thing.
- Nah.
- I love saunas, dude.
- I like saunas. I just
can't stay in them for long.
- Love it. I love getting
in the ice cold water.
Fuck, dude, it feels so good.
- Oh, I don't like that.
I don't, I don't. You do
the things that I hate.
The sauna and the ice bath.
- I love the ice cold.
Dude, the onsen for me is just
the warm up for the sauna.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
When it doesn't have
a sauna, I get so sad.
but luckily in Japan now recently,
sauna's becoming a trend.
- Oh yeah.
- For some reason.
- Yeah.
- People are obsessed with
saunas and the health benefits.
- Yeah, there's a lot of
dedicated sauna places
in Japan now.
- Yeah.
And my God, do I love sauna.
I love one, dude.
- It's very white of you.
- I think that it's very, very
white, but I fucking love it.
- But yeah, I guess going back to Tokyo,
is there any other places
or areas in Tokyo that you-
- I know it's a massive tourist trap,
but just go to Golden Gai.
It's fun.
- Golden Gai's good.
- Don't go into any bars where a guy's
telling you to go into a bar.
- Yeah.
- Go into bars that-
- Shinjuku,
there's a lot of really
cool places in Shinjuku,
but there's also a lot of
sketch places in Shinjuku,
so you really have to be careful.
- Again, if someone tells
you to go into a bar,
don't go into the bar.
- Don't go into the bar.
- That's just a rule of thumb.
- Yep.
- There's a bunch
of really cool bars, not...
so between sanchome.
Sanchome, there's a ton
of really cool bars,
behind the malls.
- Yeah, okay.
- There's a bunch of
really tightly knit areas
that have a shit ton of nice bars.
Nearly all of them I've
been into are pretty good.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I think it's mostly,
when we think of like
sketch places in Shinjuku,
it's mostly some parts of
Golden Gai and Ni-chome,
which is the gay bar district.
I've been to a few gay bars in Ni-chome,
and they're really, really
fun, but the problem is,
a lot of places they won't let you in,
unless you are going in with
someone who they already know.
- Yeah, that's true. Yeah.
- And also, a lot of them
I don't think are very
foreigner friendly either.
- Oh no. There's quite a lot actually.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, there's quite a lot.
- Okay.
- When I went filming there,
and I've been there a few times,
there's a lot of bars
that are very, very foreigner oriented.
- Oh, okay.
So if you wanna experience
gay bars in Japan,
and they are pretty dope, at
least the ones I've been to.
- Yeah.
- Go to Ni-chome.
- I mean, I think gay bars are
just pretty dope in general.
- Check out the one that I went to,
it's an anime, anisong gay bar.
- An anisong gay bar?
- Yeah.
That sounds fun as fuck.
- Oh yeah, it is.
All the dudes there were
just an absolute laugh.
- Gay bars are some of the
funnest bars you can go to.
I say this as someone
who grew up in Brighton,
where there was a bunch of gay bars.
Everyone's just so up for anything.
- Everyone's up for anything.
- I can't say.
- Also, they're just a lot of fun.
- They are.
- It's just a good vibe.
- Really good bonding experience,
if you wanna talk to
Japanese people, especially.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Daikanyama has a bunch of cool bars.
Daikanyama, that area.
- Daikanyama does have
a bunch of cool bars,
but they do get a bit costly.
- Oh, they're very expensive.
but they're super, super cool.
There's breweries in Daikanyama.
- Oh, the brewery in
Daikanyama is really good.
- Yeah, that one's sick.
- I don't think
I've been to Daikanyama.
- Yes you have, Garnt.
- Have I?
- We've been like-
- Yeah, we've been to the
brewery's in Daikanyama.
- You've gone there a ton.
- Which brewery is it again?
Is it the Spring Valley brewery?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh, that's in Daikanyama?
Oh, I thought that was Ebisu.
- Every single bar I've been
to in that area is sick.
- Okay, yeah, so I do agree with that.
- We went to the cigar bar in Daikanyama.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
- Every bar in the area I've
been to is just awesome.
- I just completely
blanked on the area name.
I was just like, that's close to Ebisu.
- Yeah, you can walk to it from Ebisu.
- Ebisu is awesome as well.
Go to Ebisu as well.
- Yeah, basically Ebisu
is just south of Shibuya.
It's one stop away, and
I say that it's like,
I actually prefer Ebisu over Shibuya,
even though Shibuya is the
more famous place to go to
because to me, Shibuya
is just way too crowded.
I don't know.
- Yeah, no, I get that.
But there's also a lot of
really cool places in Shibuya
if you know where you're looking.
- [Garnt] That's true. That's true.
- Shibuya is a lot like Shinjuku
where it is like heavily infested
with a lot of tourist traps,
but also, Shibuya is so massive
that if you go to Oyama, for example,
which is the area on the
way towards Harajuku,
that place has a lot of
really cool hidden stuff
around as well, and it's not
really that far from Shibuya.
I think, yeah, one thing I
would definitely recommend
if you're going into the big locations
is to kind of try to
venture out of the center,
because there, you do
tend to find a lot of
really cool, hidden stuff
that isn't overpriced to shit.
- Yeah.
- And that applies
to most places in Tokyo.
- Yeah, exactly.
What'd you guys think of Ikebukuro?
- I really like Ikebukuro.
- Well. there's two sides
to Ikebukuro.
- Two sides. Yeah.
- Okay, there's two sides.
- I like the east side
of Ikebukuro.
- Okay.
- Yeah, west side is
very, very, very sketch.
- Yeah.
- The east is Sunshine City,
and everything around that
area is actually pretty sick.
- Sunshine City and Otome road.
- Yeah, all that area is pretty sick.
- What I like about Ikebukuro
is that you get a little
bit of everything, you know?
It is kind of like that.
- The way you said that was so memey.
"A little bit of everything."
- A little bit of everything.
- You do kind of get a
little bit of everything.
- [Joey] Yeah. Definitely.
- If you just want
to go to an area and just,
you want to get some anime,
you got Otome Road there.
- There are some good ramen places around.
- Yeah, you got some really,
really good restaurants.
Some really, really good bars.
You've got Sunshine City.
- Yeah, and then if you
want a lot of really good
Southeast Asian restaurants
and Indian restaurants,
you go to the west side of Ikebukuro,
but it's also very scary at night.
- West side is literally like,
I don't know what happened with the vibe,
but the west side is literally
just lots of sketchy places.
- Yeah, to explain it to you,
east side and west side,
you're not gonna be able to easily wander
from one side to the other,
because it's literally
east side and west side of the station,
so you literally have to
go through the station
to get to either side, right?
- [Connor] Yeah. Or walk under.
- And it's such a big
dichotomy that I don't like...
it's literally a fucking
line that separates one,
the boujee side from the
really, really sketch side,
and I don't know how one
station can separate two areas
that are just complete
opposite of each other.
- It's crazy, on the
train, on the one side,
it's like, all you can eat, all this,
and the other side, it's like,
women, 500 yen an hour,
fuck, fuck, sex, sex,
and it's, "Whoa, whoa, whoa."
- There's a lot of brothels and host clubs
and stuff like that on the west side.
- There's gonna be a lot of guys
trying to get you into
a lot of girls bars.
- Yeah.
- Just stay on the east side.
You'll have a fucking good time.
- East side's good.
East side's good.
- You got a Round 1.
A really big Round 1.
- Very big Round 1.
- And Sunshine City is a ton of malls.
- Yeah. It's really good
shopping, really good food.
Lots of handmade stuff.
- Have we explained
what Round 1 is?
- Americans know what Round 1 is.
It's an American thing.
- Is it?
- As well, right?
- I think so. Yeah.
- The Round 1, it's arcade
plus bowling plus...
It's got everything.
- Yeah.
- I'm pretty sure you can live in Round 1.
- Yeah, yeah, right, it's
got fucking everything.
What was the place that we
filmed a video at, Joey?
- Oh, The Break Room.
- The Break Room. Is that in Ikebukuro?
- Yeah, that's an east Ikebukuro as well.
- Yeah, that's in east Ikebukuro.
I wanna go back there too.
- I wanna go back.
I've been thinking of doing another video.
- Yeah, yeah, so if
you've seen Joey's video
with me and him doing The Break Room,
where you get to just
break a bunch of shit.
They have more than that there as well.
They have like-
- The ax throwing.
- Yeah, they have ax throwing there,
and, what is it now?
- It's ax throwing.
- Yeah.
- There's the ax throwing,
there's a paint area as well,
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, where you can
spray paint, or you know, just-
- That's a really cool place.
That's in east Ikebukuro.
- And you can drink there, as well.
It's got a lot of games there as well.
- You should also go
to Bagus. I love Bagus.
- Bagus. Oh.
- Yeah, Bagus.
Just type B-A-G-U-S into
Google whenever you're here,
and I guarantee there'll be one
within walking distance
of you if you're in Tokyo,
and you can play, there's
a variety of things,
the three staples they have
are ping pong, pool and darts.
- I actually recently filmed a
video at the Ikebukuro Bagus,
which I hope it's out by the
time this episode is out.
- Is that like the grand one?
- Yeah, it's the big one
on Sunshine Road.
- Wow. Okay.
- Next to cinemas.
- What else can you do
in that one?
Because some of them have golf.
- Yeah, you can do golf,
ping pong, pool, darts,
and I think that one in Ikebukuro
has the largest selection of manga.
- Oh, okay.
- And they also have
theater rooms as well.
- Oh.
- And you can just like,
if you rent out movies
from outside of Bagus...
you can't do it inside of Bagus,
but if you go to a rental place,
you can bring in games, and
rental games and rental movies
and you just have a room to yourself
to just play games and movies.
- Also, the darts in Japan
is not, it's no basic darts.
This shit is like cyber punk darts.
The board is like a score,
there's animations and shit.
This thing is so fun. You gotta go.
And, yeah, also ordering
drinks can be kind of stressful
if you don't know any Japanese.
Basically, there will be
a phone next to your table
in a lot of these places.
You just call-
- Now they just have tablets.
- Do they? Bagus stores?
I went in the Bagus the
other day, you had to call.
- Oh really?
- Some of 'em
you have to call.
- Oh yeah,
some of them you have to call.
- You call up, you just say
the name of the drink you want
and then say, ichi, or ni.
- Yeah.
- Just say it very basic.
- Three phrases.
The third phase... phrase,
sorry, is nama beer.
- Nama beer.
- Which is just like-
- You just say nama.
- Or just nama.
Yeah, which just means the
beer on tap, or the draft beer,
or the default beer.
That's just basically
the only drink I ordered
when I came to Japan for the first time.
- That was good.
It was decent.
- Yeah, it was good.
- Japanese drink.
- Very drinkable, I'd say.
I wouldn't say it's the nicest,
but it's just very easy.
- It goes down easy.
- The thing about Japanese beer is that,
it's kind of like refreshing,
you know what I mean?
Because I was gonna say it's like water,
but that's not doing it justice, you know.
It's not American beer, you know.
- Yeah, it's not water.
- It's not Miller Lite, that's for sure.
- It's no Miller Lite.
- It's not watery.
It's just-
- It's just refreshing,
you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's very light,
without feeling like
it's a very cheap beer.
How do I? Yeah.
- It's like,
it goes down really light,
but you still get the
full taste of the beer.
- Yeah, yeah. Exactly, exactly.
- I don't know how they do it,
it's like some Japanese
wizardry happening.
- Yeah, like some of the most
refreshing beer I've had is,
I guess this is a place that
I also highly recommend,
we're going outside, we're
going way outside of Tokyo now,
is in Hokkaido, because-
- How do you get to Hokkaido, Garnt?
Where do I stay in Hokkaido?
- Where do you stay in Hokkaido?
Well, I've only stayed
near Sapporo, actually.
- Basic. Basic.
- But there are several
ways get to Hokkaido
because Hokkaido is
pretty, pretty damn big.
- Hokkaido, by the way, is
the big island at the top.
- You should go there
because the food is the best
and the drink is the best,
but, you know, you can get there by train,
but it's pain in the ass from Tokyo.
- Yeah.
- It's like four,
five hours.
- Well, I mean,
it's like four, five hours
and the last stop is in Hakodate,
which is five hour drive from Sapporo.
- Oh yeah, don't do
that. Just fly, just fly.
- Actually, I think like,
when I was stuck in Hokkaido,
the price for the planes
was actually cheaper
than the price for the Shinkansen.
- Yeah.
- Just fly. From Haneda.
- But we're talking,
if you want to explore outside of Tokyo,
maybe this is your
second trip, third trip,
you've seen Tokyo.
- Or maybe you are
just such an adventurer
that you want to go out.
- Or maybe, yeah, exactly.
Maybe you're an adventurer,
you want go out.
Fucking highly recommend Hokkaido.
- Oh yeah.
- You know.
- Sapporo is such a cool fucking city.
- [Garnt] It is. It is.
- Great bars.
- Yeah.
- Go and get something called Jingisukan.
It's fucking awesome, dude.
It's all you can eat, normally,
sometimes if you're
lucky, lamb, on a grill.
- It's like Korean barbecue with lamb,
but it's a million times better.
- It's fucking amazing, it's so good.
- Because you're gonna come to Japan
and you're gonna cream your pants
at how fucking good the food is here,
and you're like, my God,
this is like peak cuisine.
How can it get better?
It can't get better.
And then you go to
Hokkaido, and you are like,
how have they improved on perfection?
- And then Hokkaido is
like, "Hold my Sapporo."
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah,
I'll give you good food.
- Yeah, I don't know
how Hokkaido has just made
such good food even better,
because all of the best
Japanese cuisine I've had
has basically come from
Hokkaido, where it's just,
in Hokkaido, the best ramen
I've had is in Sapporo.
If you wanna-
- Best seafood I've had
is in Sapporo.
- Yeah, of course.
The best seafood I've had is in Sapporo.
If you are in Sapporo and you want to go
just easily find a ramen joint,
just go to Ramen Alley,
because there's just a bunch
of different ramen shops there.
- In the airport.
- Huh?
- Not in the airport.
- In Sapporo.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- In Sapporo, there's a
place called Ramen Alley,
and I've been there a bunch of times
just to try the different
kind of ramen stores,
and it's like,
that's where I've had the best
ramen I've ever had in Japan.
And every store there has
a different type of ramen
and it's just, they are
all fucking amazing.
They're all fucking bomb.
- I agree.
- Yeah, just Hokkaido in general.
I think if you're gonna go,
we do recommend the winter, at
least I recommend the winter
because there's a bunch of snow there,
it looks aesthetic as fuck.
- Winter Wonderland.
- Yeah, it is Winter Wonderland.
That's where the snow festival is held.
- Your plane might get delayed.
- That is-
- Like it did for Garnt.
- That is the one downside
of going to Hokkaido,
which is, because it snows a lot,
you're kind of playing
gacha with your plane.
Like, will your plane take off in time?
Will it not? Will it get canceled?
Will the entire airport shut down?
Yeah, find out when you basically go,
because you can never really
plan around that unfortunately.
- Also you can go to Niseko,
which is in my opinion,
one of the best ski resorts in Japan.
- Oh yeah, boys.
- Which is where we went,
and it's fucking great.
- Yeah, Niseko's amazing.
- Yeah.
- It'll probably be rammed with tourists
when you watching this, but
I mean, it's amazing though.
- Yeah.
- Really good food.
- I mean, I feel like I've only
been on two ski resorts now,
in Japan, and Niseko is the superior one,
but also it is very foreigner friendly.
- Yes.
- So much so
that you might encounter more foreigners
than you will Japanese people.
- Yeah, dude. It's all Aussies.
- Yeah, it's all Aussies.
- [Garnt] It is all Aussies.
- But then again, that's almost
all ski resorts in Japan.
It's just all Aussies.
- Right.
- It's good though. A really good area.
- Yeah. Really, really good.
- I've never been to Hakodate, though.
What's that like?
- Hakodate's chill.
- Hakodate's chill. I like it.
- I had the best crab in my life there.
- Yeah, I think if you
want the best seafood,
Hakodate's the place to go.
- Really?
- Yeah, because it's a port.
- Because that's where
they catch all the seafood.
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- So they have a little
fish market in Hakodate
which is called the Hakodate fish market.
- So fucking good.
- You go there
super early in the morning
and you get literally the catch
that they caught a couple of hours prior,
and it is-
- That's amazing.
- In my opinion, the best
fucking seafood I've had, ever.
- Yeah.
I think even though the
seafood is amazing in Hokkaido,
yeah, I have to say, in
Hakodate, it was the best.
- Next level.
- Right.
- Just so good. So fresh.
- Yeah.
- It's also a really small,
quaint little town as well.
You can get around very
easily with the tram system
that they have.
- Yeah.
- That's what we do.
- You can walk a lot around
a lot of the center though.
- You can, you can, but you can also go to
the nearby mountains as well.
- True, true.
- And get a really nice view
of Hakodate during the night.
Yeah, really nice.
- Where do you reckon, guys,
where do you reckon people
should get the seafood?
Just any restaurant, or do you think-
- Honestly, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean even like-
- It's all decent.
- Yeah, even like the
hundred yen sushi places
are all really good.
- All decent. All solid.
- Yeah, because the thing is,
even if you go to a big chain,
especially like the conveyor belt sushis,
because obviously the
ingredients are locally sourced,
just because, even if you
go to the same sushi chain
that you might have been to in Tokyo,
it will taste entirely
different to another sushi,
to the same sushi chain that
you have in another place.
- Sushi shane.
- Shu-shu shushi shane.
- Yeah, so even if you go
to a conveyor belt sushi,
don't expect that it will
taste exactly the same in Tokyo
as it will in another place you go to,
because I've had that exact
experience where I'm just like,
"Holy fucking shit."
I didn't realize that the
equality could differ this much
with the same chain.
- Oh yeah.
- You know, you think
you go to McDonald's,
you get, most of the time, the
same experience every time,
but with sushi chains, it's just,
it's wildly different
depending... no, well not wildly,
because the baseline is good, right?
- Yeah.
- The baseline is good.
It goes from good to fucking incredible,
is what I'm trying to say here.
- I've never had food
poisoning from fish here.
It's always been sausages.
So, take that as scientific 100% proof
that that's shit's bust.
- It's not even chicken
sashimi, or it's chicken-
- It's the goddamn sausage.
- No.
- Yeah, I think one thing
you need to take into account
is that it's actually a
lot harder than you think
to get from Hakodate to Sapporo,
if you want to explore all of Hokkaido.
- I'd say it's practically impossible
to explore all of Hokkaido,
because it's just so massive.
- Those two are the big major cities.
- Without a car, you can't.
- Yeah, without a car.
- You're screwed
without a car.
- I mean, I drove around Hokkaido a bit.
It's really fun. I really recommend it.
There's some really cool towns,
like Toyako is really cool.
- Toyako is really nice, yeah.
- Like the best soup curry
I've ever had in my life
is in Toyako.
- So good.
- Yeah, because I think the drive
between Hakodate and Sapporo
is like four hours or something.
- Three to four hours.
Even with a train.
- Which is two hours with-
- And most of the time it's just,
you're going through the mountains.
- Yeah, which is really weird,
because you can really get
tricked by the map, right,
because you go on Google Maps,
and you go Tokyo to Hakodate,
which is like that, and it's
like three hours or four hours
with the Shinkansen, and then you're like-
- There's no Shinkansen, by the way.
- Huh?
- That's not a Shinkansen.
- That's not a Shinkansen?
- The Shinkansen stops at Hakodate.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
No, no, no, yeah, yeah. To Hakodate.
It stops at Hakodate, right,
so it's like three hours.
So it's like, oh, okay,
that's not too bad,
and then you're like, okay,
maybe I can explore Sapporo as well,
because it's just over there.
- It's just there. Yeah.
- It's just
right next to Hakodate,
and then you Google Hakodate to Sapporo,
and it's like four hours,
four and a half hours.
- Yeah.
- To get like,
to get like that distance.
- Yeah.
- And you're like, "What,
how does this make sense?"
So, yeah, that's
something to keep in mind,
which is, it's a lot harder
to explore all of Hokkaido
than it may initially seem.
- I think it's because when
you're on the mainland Japan,
you're so used to everything
being so much smaller, right?
Like, all the prefectures are way smaller.
All the towns are more tightly knit.
- Or they're just easier to get to, right.
- Easily to get to.
- Yeah, easier. Exactly.
- And then you realize that Hokkaido,
in terms of prefectures,
is so much insanely larger
than the next biggest prefecture in Japan
that you kind of forget that,
oh, yeah, this place fucking is massive.
- Right.
- It's impossible
to get around.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Are there any other
places outside of Tokyo
that you guys-
- There's the obvious, Garnt.
Kyoto.
- Oh yeah.
- Are we gonna talk about Kyoto?
- What, are we nervous?
What, is it canceled?
- Kyoto's canceled.
- I don't know
if we can mention it after what Kyoto did.
- I think Kyoto is still great to go to.
- You're gonna go to Osaka, right,
because it's a fun place.
- Yeah.
- And you might wanna go to
USJ, see the Mario World.
You may as well go to
Kyoto. It's an hour away.
40 minutes I think, right?
It's like super duper close.
- It's like 30 minutes.
- Yeah.
You may as well go to both.
Kyoto is a fucking nightmare
to get around, though,
I will say.
I know there's ways you can get around
with public transport, but honestly,
if you're going there for a trip,
I'd say just taxi it around
Kyoto. It's super easy to do.
- Yeah, it's a lot cheaper
to get a taxi in Kyoto
than in Tokyo.
- And you do way more shit,
because if you just taxi
you from places in Kyoto,
you'll get so much more done.
I know that me and Chris did
so many major tourist things
in that one day.
- Yeah.
- Just 'cause we just taxied everywhere,
and did a good route.
- Yeah.
- And the ryokans in Kyoto are amazing.
Obviously super traditional.
- If you want that
super traditional Japan.
- Really good. Brilliant.
- Kiyomizu-dera, all those.
And then good thing is again,
Osaka's only 30 minutes away,
Nara, where you can feed the
deers, is only 45 minutes away.
You can go to the other
side, you can go to Shiga,
which is near like Biwako,
which is Japan's biggest inland lake.
That place is really lovely.
- Kyoto feels like the
iPhone store of Japan.
Everything is so minimal and clean.
- Yeah.
- Kyoto is so
impeccably clean.
- How do you think
it's gonna be when the country opens up
and we get tourists back?
- I'm scared, because I've
only ever been to Kyoto
with no tourists.
- Yeah.
- I've been to Kyoto with
tourists and it's hell.
- Because the reason I was just like,
"Do we want to talk about
Kyoto?" Is just because like-
- People wanna go. I
mean, they're gonna go.
We can't not mention it.
- People will want to go obviously,
but it is even more probably like,
when tourism, when the
country opens back up,
it's going to be even more of
a tourist trap than Tokyo was.
That's what it seems like.
- Kyoto is extremely popular
with Chinese tourists,
because there's a lot of
historical stuff there.
- I went during Chinese
New Year and it was-
- Oh my god.
It was literal shoulder to shoulder.
- Oh my god, you're like,
"I didn't want to eat today, anyway."
All the stores are full.
- Yeah, because Kyoto,
yeah, it's a cool place.
It's not my vibe when it comes to travel,
just because it's going
to be so busy, so packed,
and you're gonna be lining up
for the fucking 10th temple
that you've seen that day
or something like that,
and I'm just like,
"You know what? Maybe we
can skip this temple."
I go somewhere, I just
want some nice food.
- I get it, it's not for everyone,
but a lot of people love it, right.
- A lot of people love it.
Yeah, I recommend the places around Kyoto
more than Kyoto itself.
Kyoto is like a good base hub.
- I've been to Kyoto a few
times in the past two years,
and I've gotta say,
my enjoyment of Kyoto
depended on the weather.
- Oh yeah.
- Because Kyoto gets so hot.
- It does.
- And in the summer,
it's unbearable.
- Yeah.
- I just, I wouldn't even
bother going to Japan...
- Oh my god.
- ... In summer.
I genuinely, I tell people I'm like,
"Just don't. Don't come in August.
You're not gonna have fun."
- Yeah.
- Just come between October...
- Just come.
- Just come. Just come.
Just come, come right now.
Who do you want to come?
Come between October and April.
You will have the best time.
- I would mostly agree with you
except of the existence of Okinawa.
- Okay, if you're going to Okinawa,
but how many people are
gonna go to Okinawa?
Like, not that many.
- A lot of people.
- [Garnt] Okay. Like, okay, okay.
- Maybe if you go to Japan from China.
- Here's the thing.
- Because that's where I recommend.
- Tokyo sucks in the summer.
- I will fully agree with Connor,
'cause if you're gonna go to
Japan to go to just Okinawa,
then fucking go to a
Southeast Asian country.
There's so many fucking beaches there.
Okinawa is where we go
when we live in Japan,
because we don't have-
- Oh, fuck off. Ah, we colonized
this island, it's ours.
- Yeah, I mean, Okinawa is where-
- It's a joke.
- Is where we go if you live in Japan
to get to a good beach,
because there's not many choices
when it comes to good beaches
here in Japan, unfortunately.
- Yeah, god forbid mainland
Japan has a good beach.
- Well, there's some in Shimoda and stuff.
- I mean, it's-
- Izu has a bunch.
- I don't know. My standard
of beaches is very high.
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- And I feel Okinawa is the only place
that fits my Australian
standard on beaches.
- Joey was raised in sand.
- I was raised in some of the
best beaches in the world.
- Yeah, Japan doesn't
have a lot of choices
when it comes to beaches.
Funny for an island nation,
but then again, I'm from England as well,
and we have the exact same problem.
- I would argue that Okinawa
is not only great for the beaches,
but kind of very similar to Hokkaido,
where the food that you can
get in Okinawa is next level.
- I've never actually been to Okinawa yet,
so I can't comment.
- Oh dude, you have to.
- But I've only seen like the spam sushi.
- Okinawa, like spam
sushi is like, you know,
more famous one, but like there's so many,
there's so many like
traditionalist Okinawa
and Ryukyu style foods
that are just so good.
And I mean like the
booze in Okinawa as well,
'cause like in Hokkaido
you have Sapporo beer.
- Yeah.
- Right,
which is like, you drink
Sapporo beer in Hokkaido-
- Sapporo Classic.
- Which you can only get in
Hokkaido, for some reason.
- Yeah, whereas in Okinawa
there's a specific type of beer
called an Orion beer, or an Orion beer,
however you wanna pronounce it,
and Orion beer in Okinawa
is probably just as nut worthy
as a Sapporo in Hokkaido,
in my opinion.
- I thought you said Onion beer.
- Onion?
- Onion.
And then you cut the onion.
- Cut the onion in half.
- Cut that. Cut that.
So cursed.
- Yeah, but Orion, or it's spelled Orion,
but it's pronounced Orion.
- Orion.
- Orion beer,
it's like a Okinawa specific beer,
and that on a summer day
in Okinawa, is god tier.
- Yeah. Okay.
- It's so good.
And just Okinawa food in general,
if you want a different kind
of twist on Japanese food,
that you can't really get anywhere else,
I would definitely
recommend Okinawan food.
And there's plenty of
Okinawa based restaurants
in Tokyo as well.
There's a really good one
in Ikebukuro, actually,
in Sunshine City, I go to quite a bit.
So if you want a different
take on Japanese food,
I recommend Okinawan food.
- Yeah, I mean, speaking of food,
a lot of people come here,
or at least a lot of anime fans come here
expecting to enjoy like the weeb aspect,
and then pretty much everyone I talk to,
they come to Japan and they're just like,
"I stay for the food."
- Oh yeah.
- The food culture.
- Come for the anime,
stay for the food.
- Yeah, yeah. Right, right.
- Please spend your money
on food, not anime, please.
- If you're gonna spend
your money on something,
I know it's going to be hard
walking through Akihabara
and you can see some cool anime figures.
Spend your money on a good meal.
You will not fucking regret it.
- It'll be the best
meal you've probably had
in your entire life.
- Yeah.
What kind of things do you
guys recommend people try out
when they're here?
Not Ichiran ramen.
- Ichiran. Go Ichiran.
- No, no.
Wherever you are, find the filthiest,
grossest looking ramen place.
- Yes.
- Most likely the ramen
will be a 10 out of 10.
- Yes.
- Or a one.
- No, it's always a ten.
- No, no, it's never a one.
It's never a one, unless
you go to Ichiran.
- The ones that have
the fucking neon signs,
look really pretty on the outside,
they're just covering the
fact that their food is mid.
- Yeah, and the thing is,
it might look intimidating,
because obviously it
looks very traditional,
or you don't know how to order.
Most of the time, there
will be a machine, right?
- Like a ticket machine.
- Like a ticket machine,
and all you have to do
is put your money in,
and if you're having trouble figuring out
what the orders are,
because there's normally
only four ramens to choose from anyway.
- That's the good places.
- Yeah, those are the good places.
The less choice you have on the menu,
the better chance it's going to be
that it's gonna fucking bomb,
because that means that this family,
or the person running the restaurant,
has just like-
- Perfected their craft.
- They've perfected it.
They've sharpened their craft, you know?
Yeah. But most of the time
you're only gonna have
three or four ramens to pick from,
you can use the fucking
Google translate thing,
hack that...
- Life hack.
- Life hack that we use,
if you're having trouble,
but it's really not that
intimidating at all.
So you just choose your meal.
Maybe you go with the gyoza as well,
maybe you order a beer with it,
and then you just give your
tickets to the ramen guy
and he'll give you your order.
And that's pretty much it.
- Yeah. and it'll probably
be the best fucking ramen
you'll ever have in your life.
- Yeah, yeah.
Honestly, like we just said earlier,
conveyor belt sushi,
I actually prefer conveyor
belt sushi a lot of the times
to the more expensive sushi
chains and sushi restaurants.
- I think it depends for me.
I don't mind going to
the more expensive ones,
maybe once or twice a year,
but if I just want like
a consistently good sushi
then, yeah, there's nothing
wrong with conveyor sushi.
- There's a lot of places that
they're just like lunch sets
that are 2000 yen, and you
get like a bunch of sushi.
- That's true.
- Made right in front of you.
- Here's the reason why,
because with conveyor belt sushi,
it's such a good value for money,
and I remember the first
time coming to Japan
and just thinking, the sushi is amazing,
because it fucking is amazing.
I wanted to stuff myself full
with as much sushi as I could eat,
and you can't do that
with expensive chains.
- That's fair.
I prefer the ones with the conveyor belts,
but you order, and then it
comes out on the conveyor belt.
- That's most places now.
- Yeah, that's most places.
- Yeah, I know,
there are still some that
have the rotating ones.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- And it's just like,
I would rather have the
freshly prepared one, please.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so with a lot of
conveyor belt brands or places
that you go to,
they'll have a system where some of them
will literally be automated
where they'll have a plate
that gets shot to you
on a fucking treadmill.
- And the best thing is,
it's usually shaped like a bullet train.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, right?
- It's like, so thematically cool.
- It's fucking cool. It's
so cool, it's so cool.
And yeah, to this day,
I still eat as much
conveyable as sushi as I can,
'cause I think it's fucking amazing,
and I love stuffing
myself full with sushi,
and I can't do that at
more expensive restaurants.
I mean, sushi's good. Sushi's good.
But at the end of the day,
it's just fish, rice and wasabi, right?
It's fish, rice and wasabi, and...
- I also think you should
try the foreign food here.
See what their takes are on foreign foods.
It's quite interesting.
- Oh yeah.
- They do some really
good foreign food here.
I think you'd be surprised.
- Italian food, especially.
- Italian food's really good here.
Some really good burger chains.
- It's different from
Italian food in Europe.
- It's really good though.
Like, imagine that you
know that some restaurants
combine the techniques of Italian chefs,
but use Japanese ingredients,
which can be really impressive.
It's maybe not the most authentic thing,
but you'll get something new,
especially the fish here.
- Yeah.
- Oh my god.
- Definitely.
- Fish dishes in Japan, and Italian food,
are like next fucking level.
- Yeah.
- Definitely. Definitely.
- Holy fucking shit.
- The best kind of fusion.
- Oh, so good.
- What do you think about
them trying wagyu beef?
- Yeah, try it. Try it.
I mean, you know-
- Well, the thing is,
there's so many different types of wagyu.
- When you've lived here long enough,
I feel like you kind of go off wagyu.
- Yeah.
- You're like,
ah, I kind of want more meat than fat.
- Yeah.
- But the first time
you have it, it is like a, "What
the fuck? This is amazing."
- It is an explosion in your mouth.
- Yeah.
- Of flavor.
- It's food wars. It's based on like...
- Yeah.
- Pretty much.
- Eating wagyu, your mouth is just like...
- Where's the best place to get wagyu,
if you don't know what
you're looking for though?
- That's really hard to say.
- Yeah, go anywhere in Kobe, I guess,
and just get Kobe beef there.
- [Garnt] Well, let's assume like.
- Every single prefecture in Japan,
we have our own beef that is just as good.
- I think hida-gyu, in Takayama,
is probably the best like
type of wagyu I've had.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Kobe beef is like, it's good,
but it's so fatty at times
where you're just like, "Oh my God,
I dunno if I'm eating like
a piece of fat or not."
- Yeah, you're just
eating butter, basically.
- Yeah, basically. You're
just eating butter.
- Americans, you'd love
that. You love that, right?
- Yeah.
- Americans love that.
- I feel like saying teppanyaki,
you can always get wagyu.
- Yeah.
- Teppanyaki's pretty good.
- It also just depends on
how it's prepared, as well,
a lot of the times.
- Yeah.
- But what I really like
about hida-gyu, for example,
is that they literally just
put a bunch, cubes of it,
basically just on a stick,
put it on top of a fire,
just put some salt and pepper
on that dish, and boom.
It's the best fucking
food you'll ever have,
and they sell it as street food.
- I mean, Chris's favorite
food, yakitori, as well.
- Yakitori is good.
- Can't go wrong.
- Again, like-
- Do you feel like the
best types of yakitori
are the all you can eat
ones, or do you think
they should go to a more
traditional yakitori place?
- I think both are pretty good.
I think if it's the first
time you're experiencing that,
you're probably not gonna be
able to taste the difference.
I think the only ones who are like,
only opt to go to say
the more traditional ones
are the ones who have just
had so much fucking Torikizoku
that they're just like,
"All right, let me just try and be..."
- If you really wanna try
those kind of places though,
you really need to
learn the names, though.
- Yes. Yes.
- Yeah.
- Because a lot of those
places don't have a menu.
- No they don't.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah, that's true.
- Because you just walk up,
it's literally just a counter
and a dude standing there
just infinitely cooking chicken,
and you just have to say the-
- Just say negima. That's the best one.
- Negima's the best one.
- Negima's, hands down, it's
the OG. It's so fucking good.
- Yep, it's just good
chicken with some leek.
- Oh, I fucking love leek, dude.
- So good.
- Why is leek so good?
The layers dude, they taste so good.
And Japan does negi based food so well.
- Oh dude, it's so good.
- Yeah. It's really, really good.
- I can just plow down on like
50 negimas, dude. I just...
Chris always wants the tsukune.
I think tsukune is just-
- I love tsukune.
- Oh, the meatballs?
- Oh.
- Yeah.
I love it.
- Like why,
why bastardize this chicken, dude?
- What do you mean,
bastardize the chicken?
- Just rip it apart, and
shove it back together.
- What are you talking about?
- Just grind it apart
and make it into a ball.
- It's great.
- It's just like, nah, dude.
- It's the only time I will
accept boneless chicken.
- Oh my fucking god.
- Because it's-
- What, fucking ground chicken?
The reason why I don't like it is 'cause
it's almost like...
like negima is the perfect
balance between meat and veg.
Right?
- Mm.
- You get one bite of
chicken and veg, right.
- Yeah.
- It's perfect.
Tsukune is just pure, just ground meat,
and I'm like, "This is too much."
- But I like that
because it more evenly
spreads the seasoning, right,
because it's seasoned in
the ground meat, right?
- I mean, I just, I kind of
want a variation, you know.
- Well that's the great
thing about yakitori, right.
Different structure.
- Yeah, yeah.
We don't need to argue about this,
'cause we can just order our own sticks.
- Calorific ones.
There's ones where it's
meat filled with cheese.
- Pork belly. I highly
recommend pork belly as well.
- What's pork belly
called again in Japanese?
- Kakuni.
- Kakuni, yeah, that's right.
- Kakuni is really good.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] I like kakuni.
- Yeah, I mean, that's the, again,
that's what I order if I
don't want to have something
like wagyu beef, but you still want
that explosion of flavor in your mouth.
- It's like that perfect
cube of pork belly and fat.
- I'm getting fucking hungry now.
- I know, I really like-
- Now that we're just
talking about this.
- Can I go to Torikizoku
after this, dude?
I'm ready to smash down.
- I'm starting to...
- I'm getting hungry.
I've been very hungry this entire episode.
- What would you say then
is the most underrated
Japanese food for people to try
when it comes to Japan, right?
Because obviously, everyone knows
that they're gonna go to a sushi place.
They're gonna go to an izakaya, but like-
- Oh.
The one that no one
ever talks about, unagi.
Unagi's like the boss, dude.
- [Garnt] I was gonna say unagi as well.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, please try unagi.
- It is expensive.
It is expensive.
- But it's worth.
- It's an experience.
- Okay, because I remember
explaining to my mom
how I'm really into unagi,
but I had to explain to
her that it's eel, right?
- Yeah.
- She's like, "Ugh."
- [Connor] Yeah, people can be like that.
- "Why'd you like eel?
Well, that's disgusting."
And that's 'cause her
perception of eating eel
is like jellied eels.
- Slimy and...
- Oh yeah, okay, yeah.
- I'm just like, "My god.
Living in the UK has to
ruined your perception
of this fucking S tier food.
- So it's like the way it's prepared
is that it's grilled and then
it's smoked, I think, as well.
- Yeah.
- And so it's not slimy,
it's just like kind of like,
you know when you grill a
fish and it's kind of like
nice and crumbly and dry,
and then the way they season
and sauce this bad boy.
- But it's not dry. That's the thing.
- It's not.
- It's somehow moist.
- It's moist. It's good.
It's just flakes apart. It's so good.
- It has the consistency of fish.
- And it's healthy.
- A perfectly good,
flavorful, moist fish.
- So good, dude.
- You put that on a bed
of rice, really good.
- There's some really cheap
places you can get it,
but I'd say the places that
cost around 2 to 3000 yen
for a box, are probably like the places
where you'll get some really good ones.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- I've gone to places where
they charge 7,000 yen,
70 bucks for just one.
- I've gone to places where
it's a hundred bucks for one.
- Yeah.
- And it's like-
- It's good.
- It's like,
damn, it's good by like-
- Can you tell the difference
in the taste though?
- Yeah.
So, it's weird, man.
With unagi, it's like,
I feel like the subtleness of the flavors
and especially the fish,
when you get it cheap, it's so harsh,
the flavor of the unagi.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whereas like the good ones,
the sauce is kind of light.
The eel is just really, oh, I
don't know how to describe it.
Fuck, it's... I don't know.
Do you know what I mean?
- I know exactly what you mean.
- I know what you mean.
- How would you describe it?
- It's like... I don't know.
It kind of like.
- The skin, also,
the texture of the skin
on the cheap places
is really-
- Rough?
- Yeah, rough,
and kind of, it makes you feel
like you're eating something fishy,
whereas normally, when it's good unagi,
it doesn't remind you,
it doesn't feel like you're eating fish.
- Yeah, it feels like you're eating meat.
- Yeah.
- Which is like
the weirdest comparison.
- It's so good.
- It's like a meaty, fishy kind of...
- It's like a meat and fish combo,
but the best way imaginable.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So good. You have to try.
- Do you ever get like
Uber Eats unagi at all?
- I've had it a bunch.
It's generally meh, I'd say.
- You gotta go to a restaurant.
- But if you're in Japan,
you're probably not getting Uber Eats.
Don't worry about it.
- Don't waste your time with Uber Eats.
- I will say that sometimes
that if it's a nice unagi place,
you might have to reserve.
Unagi takes a while to cook.
- Yeah.
- It's like a lot of places,
especially if you're
out in the countryside-
- Especially in the summer.
- Summer, yeah, because it's
a summer food, primarily,
but you can get in winter.
It's still good.
- Yeah.
- The places in the
countryside outside of Tokyo
normally you always
have to call in advance,
and tell them that you're coming,
or that you want to book,
because it takes, I think, at
least an hour or two to cook.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's smoked and
stuff, so it takes a while.
It's really, really good.
Really, really recommend it.
And people don't really talk about it,
'cause people don't like the idea of eels.
- Yeah.
- I'm always
hyping it up, though.
I love it.
- Yep.
I mean, I guess for me,
if I can't say unagi,
if you are going to a more
expensive seafood place,
I really like uni.
- Uni.
- Yeah.
- Sea ocean. Sea ocean.
- I know Connor hates it.
Well, uni has like really grown on me
since I've moved to Japan, like
really, really grown on me.
- Yeah, dude. Fuck yeah.
- I just like, okay, you know how-
- It's my favorite.
- You know how they say,
if you take a sea shell with you
and you put your ear against it,
then you can hear the ocean.
- Yeah.
- You can hear the sea.
So me, eating uni is like eating the sea.
It's like tasting the sea.
(Joey laughing)
- It's like, if the sea
had poop and you ate it,
it would be uni.
- But the best flavored poop.
- If that is sea poop, just-
- Try it.
- I guess I'm about to-
- Then I'm a shit eater.
- I guess I'm about to play
Euphoria all over again, baby,
'cause I am a sea eating poop lover.
- Oh god.
If you know what it is,
it's on screen right now,
it's this orange looking paste thingy.
You'll recognize it because
it always stands out
in the sushi.
- Yeah.
- That thing. It looks like it...
One of these things is not like the other.
- But it's so refreshing.
- No.
- And it's so...
- You'll know which camp you're in.
- Yeah, it's...
- When you try it, please
let me know, let them know
which one you're in.
- To be fair,
I think out of the almost
maybe 10 to 20 people
that I've taken to a sushi
place and they've tried uni,
I think like 75% of
them ended up liking it.
- Yeah.
- What?
- I think it's like,
most people I think are very
thrown off with how it looks.
- I spoke to Daidus and
Emily, and they were like,
"Let's go to a sushi place."
I was like, "Sure,"
and they were like, the one
place I don't want to go
is if they have too much uni,
and I was like, "Don't
worry, I hate uni too."
Yes.
- No, it's so good.
No taste. No taste.
- It sucks.
- No taste.
But no, yeah, I really, really like uni,
and even if you don't like it,
I recommend you try it out, because-
- Yeah, try it out.
- Yeah.
- I have.
- It's a very unique flavor.
It's very refreshing.
It's nowhere on the same level
as something like fucking
natto, or something like that,
where it's like weird foods.
It's a very subtle flavor.
- Subtle?
- I think it's subtle.
- It's like bomb going off in your mouth.
- No.
- No, it's not.
What?
- No. It's subtle.
- [Garnt] It's like refreshing,
it's like eating the ocean.
- It's like a salty,
creamy type of nice flavor
that goes down.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's so weird, 'cause
you look at a sea urchin,
and you're just like,
"How the fuck can anything
edible come out of that?"
- It's disgusting.
- It's like,
what the hell is this?
- And then you crack it open, gold.
Gold of the ocean.
- Oh. (grimaces)
- Okay, I would probably recommend then,
what Japan does really fucking well,
when we think of meat
based foods in Japan,
most people are pretty
quick to go, like, wagyu,
and stuff like that.
I think, though, tonkatsu.
- In Japan. Oh, oh.
- Oh.
- Oh yeah.
- Is god tier.
- Fuck yeah.
- Which is fried... No, not
fried, but deep... pork cut.
- Pork cutlets.
- Dude, if you ever go
to Gunma, holy shit,
these things are like...
They look like they're fighting back.
These things are thick pieces of pork.
It's so good though.
Oh.
- There's this really good chain in Tokyo
that I love going to, called Maisen.
- Yeah.
- Oh, Maisen, dude.
- Maisen is god tier.
I took you there, right?
- Yeah, it's so good.
- I took Connor there.
- It's like 40 bucks though,
but like holy fuck it's worth it.
- But it is the best pork
cutlet you'll ever have.
- Can we stop recording? I
just got to order some food.
- I want to go to Maisen, dude.
- I'm so fucking hungry.
- Me acting. Dude.
- Yeah, pork cutlet, there's
nothing that can beat
a fresh pork cutlet.
- When I'm hungover, it's my go-to.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah. It's just like-
- Especially when it
has the egg. Fuck, dude.
- Yeah.
- The texture is just godly.
You bite in, and it's all crispy,
and then you get the rich inside.
It's nice and juicy. Oh my god.
- You can have it by itself,
or there's another really cool
way to eat it, which I like,
which is katsudon.
- Yeah.
- Which is where you like put it in egg
and have some onion, and you
put that on a bed of rice.
- Katsudon is my favorite.
- Yeah, katsudon is-
- I'm not a fan of katsudon.
- Really?
- Because it's like, to me, part of my...
one of my favorite things about tonkatsu
is the texture, right,
but when you put it
under egg, it just like,
it gets rid of that crunch to it.
- No, but that's replaced
with the fucking amazing
egg and pork flavor.
- I like the crunch.
I like the crunch.
- I think the uni
turned your brain to goop, bro.
- No, don't. Don't put
them in the same category.
- What are you talking
about, bro? What the fuck?
- It's that crunch.
It's that fresh crunch, it's just godly,
and by putting egg over it-
- If you get a fresh one,
you can get the crunch
with the egg and the sauce
and the onion.
- You have the katsudon at Maisen, dude,
it has the crunch.
- Oh, I can't believe you just said that.
- I tell you what it is.
- I can't believe you just said that.
It's like putting milk in your cereal.
- No.
- I prefer it.
- You get rid of the texture.
I like that crunch. I
like that fresh crunch.
- I think katsudon is
better than normal katsu,
because you get the egg,
the egg and the onions are game
changer, but with the rice,
'cause when you get the perfect ratio
of meat, egg, rice, and
onions, in one bite,
it's like food wars level, dude.
- God, I'm so hungry.
- It's the best.
I don't know what Garnt's...
Garnt's a little baby, though.
Garnt's like, dude, Garnt
asks questions like,
"Do you peel your crayons
before you eat it?"
Don't trust Garnt, with his opinions.
- I mean, it's a preference thing.
It's a preference thing.
- Of course.
- To me, the best thing about to tonkatsu
is that fucking flavor.
- The preference to eat shit.
That's what you do.
- No, no, no.
- No, no, he's got good taste
'cause he likes uni and natto,
right?
- You wanna side with a guy
who says all bread tastes the same?
No.
- No.
But I will agree uni
and natto is god like.
- They're fucking god like.
- Yeah, but again, I would like to argue
there is so much more to Japanese cuisine
than sushi and wagyu.
Like, yeah, go ahead,
eat the sushi and wagyu.
- And ramen.
- And ramen, right?
- Yeah.
- All fucking amazing.
But if you go out there and try out
some other lesser known stuff,
and there's like, we only just
fucking scratch the surface.
There is plenty of other stuff as well.
- Okonomiyaki. Maybe,
maybe you'll like that.
- Oh fuck, I fuck with okonomiyaki.
- I fuck with okonomiyaki.
You know, takoyaki as well.
You know, it kind of chooses.
- Yeah.
- Some people really like
it, some people don't.
- There's some really nice
restaurants, actually,
that do it, that are really good price.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's street food, right,
but there are some restaurants
that do it amazingly.
- But if you're gonna have
some of the best okonomiyaki
and takoyaki, especially,
you've gotta go to Osaka.
- That's true. That's true.
- Like Osaka does the best.
- Fuck, the okonomiyaki.
- The best okonomiyaki I had was in Osaka,
in this really shitty
downtown mom and pop shop.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- Where it's like
five people could fit in it,
and it was fucking amazing.
- Well, the thing is, it's just like,
I feel like the rule
with Asian food is that
if you buy it on the streets,
or if it looks fucking dirty,
that food is going to fucking be amazing.
- Oh yeah.
- And that rule
is also consistent in Japan, as well.
If you have the opportunity
to buy street food,
it's normally fucking amazing.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- I've got a question.
What about konbini food?
Where does that come into this?
- Konbini food. Uh...
- Konbini food is an experience,
I think, that's really fun
for the first couple of days.
- Yeah.
Obviously you're gonna
wanna save some money
and spend some money on restaurants,
but I'd say yeah, yeah,
you've definitely gotta try some.
- Konbini food's still great,
compared to everywhere else,
'cause I'm trying, I'm like... I'm like.
- Compared to the rest
of the world, definitely.
- Compared to the rest of the world,
'cause I'm remembering
when I first came to Japan,
I'm just like, "Damn, I
can live out a 7-Eleven
& FamilyMart my entire life."
- I did.
- And I did for a good few
months, and didn't get bored.
- You guys lived off konbini
onigiri and sandwiches
for a good while.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Because compared to the food we have
at fucking Tescos or
whatever, it's like, god tier.
- Fuck right off. Fuck right off.
- I'm gonna say it, Connor.
I'm going to say it.
- No, no, no.
- I'm going to fucking say it.
- Actually, okay, listen, right.
These sandwiches are good. They're decent.
But these sandwiches
aren't better than the ones
at the Tesco.
- I'm reserving my judgment.
I still have yet to try a Tesco meal deal.
- I know for fact you're going to-
- I know when we go to the UK
for Garnt's wedding, later,
right, I'm gonna try it out,
and I'll see which side I'm on.
- But he's pretty scared,
because I know for a fact
you're gonna like the
Tesco meal deal more.
- Okay.
- But comparing Tesco food
to fucking konbini
food, it's nowhere near.
It's nowhere near.
- Well, the sandwiches...
Okay, first of all, Joey,
here's what I'm gonna tell you.
- Okay.
- First of all,
sandwiches actually have crust on them.
- Okay. That already wins.
- All right, well what do you want?
What do you want if you
don't want a sandwich?
- I'm not saying...
Okay, I'm just saying the
sandwiches are better. All right?
- Okay, that's not an argument.
I'm saying konbini food in general.
What'd you want if you
want a Tesco meal deal,
but you don't want a sandwich?
- Get a salad.
It's all right. It's decent.
It's not great.
- I'm not going to a konbini
to get a fucking salad, dude.
- A pasty, if you want. A pasty's decent.
- It's a cold pasty, a cold pasty?
- Deviled eggs.
- No, no.
- Deviled eggs?
- No.
- Deviled eggs. You beat deviled eggs?
- What's that?
- Oh, it's like a pork ball
with batter, egg in the middle.
Oh god.
- You gonna compare that
to fucking good fried chicken?
- Listen, listen, the
other stuff is better,
but the sandwich game is
absolutely appalling in Japan.
I still like them, but the
UK sandwiches are better.
- But the sandwich in konbini
section is one tiny section
compared to literally the entire-
- Also, why's there no meal deal in Japan?
What's up with that? Why
is there no meal deal?
Why is there no drink?
Get your own tea, get a
sandwich and a little snack.
- Because you have an
infinite amount of choice
at a konbini.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's just called going to
the food section at a konbini.
- Also, I don't like in Japan
how it's really hard to get
a normal sized bag of crisps.
Like, they're all big sized, right?
Have you noticed that?
- Yeah.
- It's like, you can't have-
- You're talking about
the small ones?
- You can't just have
one portion of crisps,
it's like you're committing to three bags.
- Yeah.
- Well to be fair, though,
when you do buy the big ones,
though, like 60% of it is air,
which is probably the equivalent to one
small size bag of chips.
- Yeah. But yeah, I mean like, if,
especially if you come from England,
I think Connor's romanticized
Tesco meal deal is a lot.
- Absolutely not.
- Because you got
the sandwiches, and if
you go to a konbini,
you also have sandwiches,
but you also have the
onigiri fried chicken,
you have some yakatori
sticks, you got bentos.
- I don't fuck with the
yakatori sticks at konbinis.
I wouldn't get them.
- You wouldn't get them?
- Sticks of fried chicken.
- Well, you get beef balls.
- You get fried chicken.
- You get beef balls as well.
- I've had the sausages there before.
- Did you get food poisoning from them?
- I did not.
I've had the 7-Eleven... not corn dogs,
the ones like just hot dogs on a stick.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's alright.
- The corn dogs at 7-Eleven
are kind of alright.
No, they're all right.
- I've never had one.
- I like corn dogs, though.
- It's hard to fuck up a corn dog.
- If you go to a Ministop,
which you won't see often,
they have soft serve.
- They are the rarest.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, the Ministop soft
serves are godlike.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- They specialize in soft
serve, and it goes hard.
- But Ministops are like
the SSRS of konbinis,
because I think in Tokyo,
I think it's only like
0.5% of konbinis in Tokyo
are Ministops.
- Most of them I feel like
are around Shinjuku, weirdly.
- Yeah?
- I see a lot in Shinjuku.
- Yeah.
I know there's one up
north where I used to live,
but that was very rare.
- They're good, though.
- I was very happy I
lived near a Ministop.
I was like, "Oh yes, I've
pulled the SSR. Let's go, baby."
- Yeah. Blimey, there's so much.
- Hell yeah.
- You're spoiled for choice
with food, and however
much you want to spend,
you can spend.
- Yeah.
- I guess we've gotten a lot
of the basic things out the way
of your first visit to Japan.
What if someone has a
little bit more time,
and has been to Japan a few times,
where would you guys
recommend that they go to?
- Well, I mean, we did
the Shimanami Kaido,
which is on the cycling special.
- Honestly...
- Hiroshima.
- Setonaikai, that inland
sea area is fucking gorgeous.
Beautiful.
- Fucking incredible,
and I really, really,
since the cycling special,
I really want to go back there.
I really wanna go back there
and do the route again.
Basically, just look
at the cycling special,
and just look how beautiful it was, right?
- Because the best thing
about it is that you have
all of Hiroshima that's near there,
you have right next to that,
there's a prefecture called Okayama,
where I went there for a video.
There's this little small
town called Kurashiki,
which is this really
cool retro style town.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- That's just basically just this hill
that overlooks the inland sea,
and it's so fucking gorgeous.
And then, if you wanna
cross that inland sea
and go to Lake Shikoku,
you have places like Ehime,
which is really kind of down to earth
and kind of chill.
- Yeah.
- Shikoku's okay. Yeah.
- Shikoku's okay.
- There's not much to do.
- It's not the most
exciting thing, but if
you're a little bored of-
- Kochi's all right.
- Yeah, if you're a little
bored of the kind of
whole city life of Tokyo,
and stuff like that,
and the main cities,
that's really, really nice.
- Yeah, and if watching
the cycling special
kind of like intimidated you,
don't worry, you don't need to
do the entire route in a day.
If I was to do it again,
I would definitely not do it in a day.
- You can also rent a car
and just drive across it.
- You can also rent a car,
but if you also wanna keep healthy,
work out those muscles,
then I do actually highly
recommend the cycling route.
I highly recommend you doing
that in two days, maybe,
three days.
Now that you think back,
what do you think is the optimal
time you would recommend?
- I would do that in a day.
- You would still do it in a day?
- Yeah.
- I reckon, if I didn't
want to be hurting,
I'd say at least two days.
- I think it was just annoying
'cause we were filming.
I think it would've been pretty fun
if I could just power off.
- There's a couple of
the islands in between
where admittedly, there
isn't a whole lot going on,
but like the first couple of islands,
that's closer to Hiroshima,
there's still a really
cool town vibe to it,
and there's like a lot of
cool beaches there as well.
So if you go to summer,
there's some genuinely nice beaches there.
- It depends how fit you are, I guess.
If you really aren't
fit at all, I wouldn't.
- Yeah, maybe just stick
to the first island.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, you know,
if you're somewhat active
and you'll have no problem
cycling, then yeah,
I'd just do it all one day.
It's very, very beautiful.
- You can also just cycle
around Hiroshima as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, honestly it's some
of the most beautiful views
I've had in Japan.
- Yeah.
- And that's saying a lot,
'cause a lot of Japan
is photogenic as fuck.
It's a bit unfair.
I mean, I guess, sticking on that vein,
if you wanna go see Mount Fuji,
I do recommend going to one
of the lakes around there.
I can't remember the name exactly.
- Kawaguchiko.
- Kawaguchiko. Yeah.
Lake Kawaguchiko is just like,
you can also cycle around there.
You can rent a bike.
Me and Sydney have gone on a date
where we've rented a bike
and just cycled around the inside lake.
It's kind of unfair
where you go to a place
and everything looks Photoshop,
even though it's real.
You take a picture there...
We've taken a bunch of pictures there.
I dunno when was the last
time we went there was the...
- When we went camping, right.
- When we went camping.
- Yeah.
- And Luke took a bunch of pictures,
and we took a bunch of pictures,
and everyone took a bunch of pictures,
- You get a picture, I get a picture.
- And no matter what,
it was impossible to take a
bad picture at that place.
- It just looked like a postcard.
- Especially when it's clear.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which it was when we
went, we got very lucky.
- Yeah.
- But, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know, because I remember
when we did the journey
across Japan 2, to Mount Fuji,
a lot of people thought
that by the end of it,
we had just green screened
ourselves in front of it,
because it just looked that good.
- It's so weird being in
that place and you just like,
I literally feel like I'm
looking at a green screen,
or it's, this is a screensaver right now.
- Like a desktop wallpaper.
- Yeah, I'm looking at a screensaver.
- I'm waiting for the
pipes animation to start.
- Yeah.
It's so surreal that a place
can look that photogenic,
but just exist in real life
without any plugins or
any Photoshop edits.
- No RTX on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No RTX on.
- We'll say it's probably
one of the places you might
want to drive, though.
It's kind of annoying to
go by train and stuff.
- Yeah, there isn't a whole lot of train.
I'd say outside of the major cities,
like Osaka, Tokyo, Sapporo,
and stuff like that-
- Driving is better off.
- Driving is your best friend.
- You'll have such a hard time
if you are trying to do
it by public transport,
as I'm sure Garnt probably is experienced,
'cause you only do it
all by public transport.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually on that vein, I guess
an app I highly recommend
is the app that we use, is DiDi,
which, there is a few taxi apps in Japan.
DiDi.
- Go Taxi.
- There's Go Taxi,
but DiDi is the most, I
guess, foreigner friendly,
because it's you can-
- It's all English.
- So it's all English.
- Accept any card.
- Yeah, it'll accept any card.
With other apps, it's been really finicky
with the types of cards
that it will accept.
- Oh my god. Japan taxi, and
Go taxi, whatever it is now.
Oh my god.
- It is-
- I have a Japanese card,
and it just keeps denying it.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
I have a Japanese card. It denies it.
- So annoying.
- I have a foreign card, it denies it.
I have like cards from Thailand
and the UK, and it's just,
it doesn't want to accept anything.
It doesn't wanna accept anything.
So I dunno what card it will accept.
So yeah, I highly recommend
DiDi over Uber here.
Would you say so? Because Uber-
- I know you can use Uber if you want to.
- Yeah, you can use Uber, but-
- Whatever you're comfortable with.
- Yeah, I think DiDi is,
I think there's more taxis on DiDi.
Yeah, and it's the best in between,
because DiDi is not as popular
as a Japanese app like Go Taxi,
but it is still way more friendly if you-
- Unfortunately, Uber's just
not really a thing here.
- No.
- Uber Eats is.
- Uber Eats is, but the
actual Uber service.
- I know some people
who use it religiously.
- Yeah.
- But mainly for food, I guess.
- Also, hailing cabs is
really, really easy here.
- Especially in Tokyo.
- If you're confident enough
in just telling them where to go,
it's really, really easy.
- Yeah.
- Obviously that's a big if.
- I understand it's a tall,
a tall ask.
- But I think
for the most part, if you are in Tokyo,
the train system is just so convenient.
You probably-
- Google Maps.
- ... very rarely will have to use a taxi.
- Don't try to learn the
maps. Just use Google Maps.
- Yeah.
- It's pretty simple.
- It routes it out for you.
- Follow the pretty colors.
- Anyone who says
they know a better route
is absolutely lying.
Google literally knows the best route.
I wish that people would
shut up being like,
"I know the streets better."
No, you don't.
Google has every fucking
satellite in existence
and billions of data.
It knows where to go.
- To be fair,
there has been times where
I've looked at Google
and I'm like, "Nah, dude, you're
gonna the aesthetic route."
- Sometimes, Google wants
to make your life easier
to a point where it's like,
"Listen, it's just quicker
if I just walk here."
- Yeah.
They're like, "No, we were gonna
make it so you don't walk."
And it's like, yeah... but
generally, for if you wanna get-
- You're gonna have to change
three different trains.
- If you wanna get A to Z,
Google will generally
tell you the best way,
and you could tell it's to
fewer changes or more changes.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- It's never failed me in Tokyo.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- Even outside of Tokyo.
Driving, I use it for driving.
I bought one of those shitty
little things on Amazon
that you stick on the air fans.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Hold my phone.
- Hold your phone.
- It's Gucci, man.
- Yeah, that's good.
- I'm good.
- Is there any other places
you guys would recommend
a bit out of the box?
- I've never been to Kyushu.
What do you think, Joey?
- Kyushu is great.
I think Kyushu is underrated as hell.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- One place I really, really
liked in Kyushu was Kumamoto.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- The Kumamoto, yeah,
where Aso is, the volcano.
Mount Aso is.
- Yeah.
- But like, I think
Kumamoto is really cool
because it's like, it's, again,
this huge like volcanic caldera,
but it's also like, it
weirdly reminds me a lot
of the kind of plain, open plain places
that I went to a lot in
Australia and in England
and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't look like Japan.
- Right.
- And it's so weird, but
it's really, really cool.
If you like your kind
of mountainous areas,
it's really dope, and also,
you're really close to Nagasaki as well,
which is a really dope city.
Nagasaki is a super cool city,
that's very vintage feel.
It has a very European feel as well,
because a lot of like European settlers
came in and out of Nagasaki.
- Ah, okay.
- Yeah, I don't know. Kyushu,
I think, is really underrated.
Has some really good food as well.
- I've always wanted to go.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
- Yeah, I still haven't
been to Kyushu as well.
- You can go to Oita as well,
which has the other
really massive onsen area.
- I've heard of Oita. And there's Beppu.
- Yeah, Beppu.
Beppu's a really cool onsen place as well.
- Gotta fly there.
I wouldn't recommend
taking the bullet train.
- You can take the bullet train to Hakata,
- It's like ten hours, though.
- But it's like,
yeah, seven or eight hours.
- Oh my god.
- From Tokyo.
- I didn't know it was that far.
- Very far.
- Yeah, it's very far.
I mean, to Hiroshima, it's
like five hours, right.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- And it stops a bunch.
- And that's not even in Kyushu.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean I guess one place
that I don't really hear
people talking about
is obviously, if you're a wine lover,
like me and Sydney are,
you can go to the wine capital of Japan,
even though wine's not as well known here.
But I mean, we discovered the place
because we're not, I'm not a big sake fan.
I'm not a massive sake fan,
but there are plenty of
places to try sake in Tokyo,
and basically anywhere you go into Japan,
but if you wanna have a little taste
of the Japanese wine culture here,
because it's not very well talked about,
you go to Koshu Valley, it's
in the Yamanashi prefecture,
which is, you can literally
make it a day trip.
- Oh yeah.
- If you wanted to.
It's just about an hour an
hour and a half out of Tokyo,
you can literally just go on the JR line
and go to the stops around Koshu Valley.
There is one place I do
recommend if you are interested.
I believe the building is
called Budou-kyo, I think.
- Budou-kyo.
- Yeah.
- Grape Hill.
- Yeah, yeah. Grape Hill.
- It's good to do Grape Hill.
- I believe that's the place,
because that's the place
I've talked about before,
where you can go in and
they have a wine cellar
with about a hundred different wines.
You pay 13 bucks,
and you can try as many wines as you like,
and that's it.
- It's self pour.
They give you a little cup
and you can try as many wines as you like.
There's little bowls where
you can spit out the wine,
if you don't like the taste of the wine.
- Especially if it's just 13
bucks to get munted on wine.
- Yeah, I've done it, I've done
it plenty of fucking times.
It's a really, really good experience,
and then there's a really
nice restaurant up there
where you can see the
entire view of Koshu Valley
and you can see all the grape
farms, and all the grapevines.
- Mm.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that's cool.
That doesn't look like Japan.
- Yeah, it's got such a good fucking view
and me and Sydney go
there for a yearly trip
to try out the different wines there
that come out every year.
- Yeah, you can, I think I drove there,
and there's decent parking.
- But if you do like saki,
I would recommend Nigata.
- Nigata. Ah, yes.
- Nigata is like the capital of saki,
and rice fields and stuff.
I went to a similar thing,
like to the wine thing.
- Vending machines?
- Except it was all
sake, for like 20 bucks.
- Were there vending machines?
- And you could taste test.
Yeah, the vending machine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's two stations that have it.
- Yeah.
It's basically all around Nigata,
it's just all really, really
nice sake based stuff.
- Chris dragged me to it.
- Yeah, so if you like sake,
go to Nigata. If you like
wine, go to Yamahashi.
- But also, in the
Nigata vending machines,
there's also umeshu, plum wine.
- Ooh, yeah.
- Really good.
- They do really good plum wine.
- 'Cause I don't like sake,
so I always go to the umeshu,
which is like nectar of the gods.
It's wonderful.
It's just like sugary goodness.
Oh, it's so good.
It's very good.
- It's so bad for you though.
- Yeah.
- It's like 100% sugar.
- Fortunately umeshu is a
bit too sweet for my pallet.
otherwise I probably would like it more.
- I couldn't drink it straight, but like,
you mix it with something like soda.
- Soda. Oh, god.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, Nigata, I've been there a bunch.
It's okay.
There's not really much to do there,
but the vending machine is sick.
There are ski resorts near it,
so in the winter, if you're coming.
- Go to Myoko, which is a
really decent ski resort.
- Very popular.
And in Tohoku area, in
general, no one really goes to,
but it's pretty chill.
I've been there a ton,
obviously with Chris.
I'm sure you have as well.
- Yeah, I love to.
- Tohoku's fun.
- I mean, my family's from Tohoku.
- Yeah. Right. I mean, Sendai's chill.
- Yeah.
- Yamagata's fun.
- Iwate's fun as well.
- Go visit
the Abroad in Japan studio, of course.
- Oh my god, yeah.
Go raid is...
Dox Chris's Abroad in Japan.
- Morioka is really fun, in Iwate.
- Yeah, Morioka's chill.
- Which is above Sendai.
- Morioka's chill.
- Yeah, that one's really fun.
- Fukushima, obviously, is
fun. We've been there a bunch.
- Yeah.
- Fukushima.
Yeah. Oh yeah.
- We drifting in Fukushima.
- Yeah, we went drifting there.
- A lot of cool areas in the
north that doesn't really
ever get spoken about as
a tourist destination.
- Yeah, I think it's because
Tohoku's just so big.
- It's really big.
- A lot of the biggest...
I mean, I think Iwate is the
second biggest prefecture
after Hokkaido.
- It's a cool place, though.
- Really cool place.
- I've had some really amazing
food and drink in that area,
and it's just kind of
nice to go somewhere,
'cause especially if Kyoto's
too touristy for you,
definitely Tohoku is
not gonna have tourists.
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- And it's a good time.
- Way, way chill.
- I've always had fun with Chris there.
- Yeah, 'cause I mean,
especially one of the
biggest things about Kyoto
is that it's just too
crowded, and you can get-
- It's crowded even now, and I don't-
- Is it crowded now?
- It's sort of crowded.
I mean, I don't know.
Some seasons I've been, it's been dead.
Depends on the day you go,
obviously weekdays it's dead.
- Yeah.
- But on some weekends it's still busy.
So I'm like, god forbid come
here on a peak tourist season.
- Is there a prefecture or area of Japan
you've always wanted to go
to, but you haven't been yet?
- Kyushu. I've always
wanted to go to Kyushu.
- I really still haven't been to
and really wanna go to Aomori.
- Oh I wanna go to Aomori too.
'Cause it's in between
Hokkaido and Morioka.
- And I'm just like,
why would I not just go
to Hokkaido at that point?
- But Aomori has really cool,
like you can do apple picking.
- Apples. Apples is
what they're famous for.
- Apples is what they're famous for.
Really good food.
Really nice Winter
Wonderland places as well.
I've heard it's really fun.
- I want to go to Aomori.
- What about theme parks?
- I've never been.
- Huh? You've never been?
- I'm not huge-
- I mean,
you've still been to
Disneyland, though, haven't you?
- Yeah.
- I don't like Disneyland.
I'm the wrong person to ask.
- Yeah, I don't like theme parks either,
but USJ is pretty fun, in Osaka.
- I've been to USJ.
- Yeah.
- It's decent.
- So you just said you've
not been to any theme parks,
you've literally been to-
- I lied. I lied.
- [Garnt] You've literally been
to two of the biggest ones.
- The biggest one,
Fuji-Q, I haven't been to,
so I feel like my opinion doesn't count.
- But yeah, I mean, Fuji-Q
is more like the Six Flags,
right, it's the thrill seeking theme park.
- I like thrill rides,
and I was kind of disappointed by USJ.
I thought there was gonna
be more thrill rides.
I don't know why I thought that.
- I think you're better off in Fuji-Q.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I figured I'll probably like Fuji-Q more.
- Because I hate thrill rides,
and I went to Fuji-Q and I'm like,
oh, if you love thrill rides,
this is the place to go.
- You can go to a rollercoaster
and have a view of Fuji.
How awesome is that, right?
That's pretty badass.
- Yeah.
- Where's Thorpe Park with that?
What does Thorpe Park have?
What the fuck does Thorpe
Park have? The car park?
- Well Thorpe Park's good.
What the fuck are you on about?
- It is good. It is good.
Just, like, how can it like... you know.
I mean, Fuji is just one of
the best views you can have.
- Have you been to Fuji-Q?
- Hmm?
- I've been outside it, and I've-
- Well great.
- I've driven past it.
- No shitting on Thorpe
Park. Hold on, Garnt.
- I'm not shitting on
Thorpe Park, but I mean-
- I mean, we all drove past Fuji-Q
when we went fucking camping.
- Did we?
- Yeah.
- I was fucking asleep.
I didn't remember that.
But it was just a really
nice, aesthetic area.
I don't know. I just like...
- It's good, but you
know, I mean, come on.
It can't be no Thorpe Park.
- No Nemesis Inferno, were you gonna say?
- It's not Alton Towers, though, is it?
Alton Towers is so good. We'll take you.
- I don't like theme parks, though.
- Yeah, he literally just said
he doesn't like theme parks.
- I literally just said
I don't like thrill rides or theme parks.
- I thought you were just joking.
- No, I don't.
- Why the fuck would you not like them?
- USJ Nintendo Land is
the only one I liked.
- What?
- But that's obvious,
because I'm a Nintendo sim.
- Why don't you... what? Why?
- I'd rather go fucking to
the arcade, or watch a movie.
- But yeah, I mean,
is there anything else
you guys want to mention?
- Not off the top of my head.
- Yeah.
- Japan's great.
- Well that's our starter guide
to having a fun time in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Starter guide.
- On your next vacation.
- Our starter guide two hour podcast.
- Yeah, obviously we haven't all gone
to every single location in Japan.
I eventually would like to go
to every single prefecture in Japan.
That's my life goal.
But yeah, still a lot I haven't been to.
- It sucks, because a lot
of the stuff I love going to
is just like, yeah, it's
good food, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- Just go to a place for food.
- Honestly, honestly,
like we said earlier,
a lot of the big draw
of going traveling now
is just trying the food
in that prefecture,
trying the food in that area,
because fucking, if, like
we said earlier earlier,
the food here is absolutely
amazing, and that's the real...
you know, you don't come
here for the anime figures,
you don't come here for
the fucking temples.
You come here for the amazing food.
That's the real reason to come to Japan.
- Unagi. Katsudon.
- Just go out there and
just try a bunch of-
- Try everything.
- People come here for the
fucking sakura blossoms,
you're gonna take a few pictures,
and then you're gonna have
the amazing food, okay.
That's it. That's it.
- The sakura is only amazing to watch at
because you're fucking sipping
on some super nice sake,
eating some really nice food.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's true.
- Right?
- Exactly, exactly.
- It all comes back to the food.
- It all comes back to the food, okay.
I literally revolve my trips in Japan
around the restaurants and
the food I could try there.
- You have to, you have
to. It makes the trip.
- It sounds like a joke,
but it's really not.
That's the highlight of my
trip, a lot of the times.
- You know, if you go to Japan
and this episode is
somewhat helpful to you,
please let us know at some point.
We'd love to... maybe not right now
when this episode goes live,
but maybe in a few months
you might use it, or years.
- Hopefully.
And let us know
if any of the tips are useful.
We'd love to know what
you liked and didn't like
about this episode.
- But you know who especially loves Japan?
The Patrons.
- Oh.
- Oh, beautiful Patrons.
- They would all love Japan.
- Of course they would.
- Oh, they're so good. They're so good.
- Because they definitely
don't love anime.
- They love the show,
which means they love Japan.
- They watch Trash Taste,
so they definitely don't
watch it because of the anime.
- Fuck, dude.
- But hey, if you like
to support the show,
then go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- [Connor] Fuck yes.
I'm gonna go eat some food and then sleep.
- Can we go to a fucking Torikizoku?
- I'm fucking starving.
- Is there one nearby this office?
- I want some good food now.
- I want some good food. Let's go eat.
- All right, see you guys next week.
- Bye.
(exhausted music)